Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Dinos, es läuft super, wenn es so weitergeht, kann ich die Meterebene bald wegen Reichtums schließen.
Hast Recht, dass mit dem Testzentrum war echt eine super Idee.
Netzpolitik Nummer dreihundertsiebenundneunzig und äh wir gucken auf den Kalender und da steht dritter Juni zwanzig einundzwanzig. Direkt aus der,
aus dem Geldspeicher live zu euch ausgespielt tja,
Hier werden, wir sind ja, wir sind ja eigentlich in gewisser Hinsicht auch schon immer irgendwie ein Testzentrum gewesen, nicht, weil wir hier so die Ideen der Leute, die so alle so draußen so sind, dann doch dem einen oder anderen Test äh unterziehen.
Ja und da müssen wir auch manchmal wirken und manchmal tut's hinten ein bisschen weh.
Nur mit der Abrechnung war es dann doch ein bisschen schwierig, also irgendwie wollten die dann immer nicht bezahlen.
Es war seit es war seit Monaten das offene Geheimnis,
dass dass diese, dass dieser Testzentrums betrug so einfach möglich ist. Es ist wirklich,
Eine Katastrophe. Ich habe das ja auch Leuten gesagt, hier pass auf, die machst du ganz einfach folgendes, ne? Du hattest eine gastronomische Einrichtung, die geschlossen war, ne? Jetzt hast du.
Corona helfen dafür kassiert, dann gründest du die Testzentrums UG,
hat natürlich mit deiner äh oder GmbH oder was auch immer, ne? Die hat natürlich mit deiner gastronomischen Einreichung Einrichtung nichts zu tun, mietet,
marktüblichen, also sehr niedrigen Preis diese Location, die du da hast, ne? Damit du deine Corona-Hilfen nicht großartig verfeuerst. Und diese Testzentrums UG.
Da sitzen dann Leute, die hat die das Gesundheitsamt ausgebildet, ja, die kriegen kostenlosen wie teilweise sind das ja offenbar auch nur Videokurse
wie das läuft, ja? Und dann setzt du die da hin und dann werfen die einfach einen Schnelltest nach dem anderen weg und schreiben Abrechnungen.
Und dann kriegst du die Kohle. Das ist it's free money. Ja wer wer es ist so und.
Es läuft aber nicht überall so.
Nein, es ich war auch, ich war gebe ich zu, ich war gestern in einem ähm in einem Testzentrum.
Kann ich auch sagen wo das war, weil ich da gleich eh nochmal drauf eingehe. In der Kultur Brauerei in Berlin.
Und ähm wurde mir dann übrigens gesagt, äh ich soll ins Kulturzentrum in der Corona-Brauerei gehen, an sich,
genau und das war wirklich höchstprofessionell,
somit reingehen, scannen, QR-Code, zack, bumm, äh Abstrich, nächste, zack und die Person, die die Abstriche genommen hat, hat das nur nach hinten durch den Fenster weitergereicht, wo dann die äh Testdurchführungen waren. Das war wirklich ähm.
Eisern schnell, war beeindruckend optimiert und so. Aber ja, das das diese einfache Abrechnung zu Betrügen führt, ist ja klar. Gleichzeitig übrigens hier gestern auch noch gelesen,
In Berlin gab es ja ähm letztes Jahr war das diese ähm Soforthilfen, Corona-Soforthilfen. Da konntest du dir relativ unbürokratisch durchausfüllen einer Webseite fünftausend Euro aufs Konto überweisen lassen und dann ungefähr einen,
Monat oder zwei später hast du dann die Drohbriefe bekommen, in denen dir gesagt wurde, na, wenn du hier übrigens falsche Angaben gemacht hast und so, ne, dann hast du
betrogen und da kennen wir keine Gnade. Und das können die natürlich auch sehr einfach äh prüfen, weil die ja dann irgendwann deine Steuererklärung sehen, ja? Ähm.
Woraufhin äh verschiedene Leute dieses Geld natürlich auch zurück überwiesen haben, beispielsweise weil sich ihre, weil sie ihre finanzielle
Situation gelöst hatten, ja? Ich gehöre zum Beispiel zu den Leuten dazu, die das ursprünglich beantragt hatten, weil ich da in diesem ersten,
sind natürlich alle möglichen. Alles wurde erstmal eingefroren, ne? Alle möglichen
Aufträge, Projekte, Pipapo konnten nicht stattfinden, eine nach der anderen. Und dann habe ich auch gedacht, okay, krass, ne, hier, jetzt muss ich eine äh Strecke überbrücken.
Nehme ich hier dieses äh Helikoptergeld in Anspruch. Habe ich auch gemacht und dann hat sich diese Situation aber relativ schnell bereinigt, weil ich ja eben sehr gut remote arbeiten kann, sodass sich dann eben meine Einkommenssituation sehr schnell
korrigiert hat. Außerdem gab's eh nichts, wofür ich das Geld hätte ausgeben dürfen, weil Durst das ja nur für Miete und sonstige Dinge ausgeben, aber nicht um,
dein Einkommen zu kompensieren. Also habe auch ich dieses Geld dann halt, ne, nach ähm.
Nachdem quasi der Kontostand sich korrigiert hatte, einfach zurück überwiesen. Jetzt liest du, dass ausgerechnet die Leute, die es zurückgegeben haben,
Die kriegen jetzt die Strafverfahren an die Backe. Geht's irgendwie Holm Friebe, ist ein prominenter Fall, den sie jetzt da irgendwie äh äh deswegen, weil er es zurück überwiesen hat, ein ähm Ermittlungsverfahren wegen irgendwie
subventionsbetrug an ja weiß ich nicht keine Ahnung.
Zurück überwiesen, also hat er das ja offenbar unberechtigt beantragt. Während ich genug Leute kenne, ja, die ähm.
Wo ich Zweifel habe.
Die jetzt in die Privatinsolvenz gestlittert wären, wenn sie mal einen Monat äh keine fünftausend Euro auf dem Konto haben, ne? Oder zwei oder drei. Äh ich will da, ne, also ich.
Ich persönlich habe mich äh erstens berechtigt gesehen, das in Anspruch zu nehmen, aber zweitens auch äh gesehen, dass sich die Situation so geklärt habe, dass ich darauf nicht angewiesen bin, also habe ich's äh zurückgegeben.
Und äh denke, das ist äh gehört sich natürlich auch so, dass man eben schaut, dass solches Geld bei denen auch ankommt, wo es äh
wird, ne? Und äh ich finde das auch total richtig übrigens, stehe ich total dahinter,
dass man das jetzt Eisen hat kontrolliert und schaut, wer sich da äh das Geld erschlichen hat, ne? Gab's ja auch diese betrügerischen Seiten und Hasse alles nicht gesehen, ne.
Das finde ich äh bin ich also total äh dabei. Ich würde nur jetzt mal so schätzen, dass diejenigen, die es zurückgezahlt haben, wahrscheinlich der falsche Ermittlungsansatz sind. Ich würde eher mir die anschauen, die das Geld noch haben, aber,
Meine ich.
Du mit deiner einfachen Logik immer.
Ich immer mit diesen einfachen Lösungen, ne.
Ja
Aber nochmal zu den Testzentren äh bist du da jetzt ein bisschen gesprungen. Also es gibt auch Gegenbeispiele. Es gibt auch äh Gemeinden, die das schlicht anders organisieren, sodass die Beauftrag
Also es gibt ja den Unterschied zwischen diesen freiarbeitenden Schnelltest-Zentren, die man vor allem in den
in den äh dicht besiedelten Gebieten, also in den Großstädten natürlich vor allem hat, ne, da macht dann einfach irgendjemand äh auf und ist ja auch für viele Läden
sagen wir mal, auch eine eine legitime und schöne Geschichte, ja, also Läden, die einfach nicht haben, öffnen dürfen, die die Räumlichkeiten aber ohnehin haben und die dann eben so nutzen können, also es wird das nicht generell
so verteufeln. Ähm viele haben da sicherlich auch zu knappsen und durchaus auch vor, das richtig abzurechnen. Ich habe auch so den Eindruck in dieser ganzen Debatte. Da werden jetzt halt manche Fälle,
großgezogen und äh man tendiert schnell dann dazu
alle dabei einen Kamm zu scheren. Es gibt aber dann auch die Situation in den kleineren, ländlichen Gemeinden, die unter Umständen gar nicht so dieses äh Heilsversprechen von viel Umsatz äh haben, weil da einfach nicht so viele Leute wohnen oder es nicht so oft in
Anspruch nehmen würden
Äh da ist es dann teilweise so, dass die äh dass bestimmte Betreiber mehr oder weniger von der Gemeinde beauftragt werden, das zu machen. Und zumindest in.
Ich kenne jetzt auch nicht alle Fälle. Ich habe das nicht durchrecherchiert, aber ich so anekdotisch gibt's halt ähm dann die Situation, dass die dann eben diese Schnelltests auch bei der Gemeinde einkaufen.
Das heißt,
die ganze Zulieferung äh und damit dann auch die Abrechnung, wie viele äh äh Tests da jetzt äh geliefert werden et cetera, läuft da schon mal in anderen Bahnen und äh gibt da sehr viel mehr Kontrollmöglichkeiten.
Also wir haben, ich habe ich kann das, glaube ich, erzählen, ich war an der, also ich ich weiß, von welchem Fall du gerade sprichst. Wir äh beschäftigen uns ja beide so ein bisschen mit dem Festival-Kontext und ähm,
Es ist ja, glaube ich, auch bekannt, dass das äh Fusion Festival eine PCR Labor jetzt da stehen hat. Geiles Teil in äh auf dem Gelände. Und äh,
natürlich weil sie dort PCR-Tests anbieten, natürlich auch sich als Bürgertestzentrum
für die Region anbieten und da ist es tatsächlich so, ne, dass es äh dünn besiedeltes Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
Land, äh ne, da kommen dann mal die paar Leute aus der äh aus den angrenzenden Dörfern vorbei, da machst du ein paar Stunden am Tag auf und hast ein paar wenige Kundinnen.
Das ist absolut richtig. Ähm allerdings, als ich da gesehen habe, wie die.
Abrechnungsmodalitäten sind, habe ich mir auch gedacht, wenn du das jetzt halt irgendwo anders hin überträgst, ähm ist das sehr,
kannst du das sehr lukrativ machen, ne? Und ich kann eigentlich nur sagen, wenn ihr in irgendwelchen
dünn besiedelten Regionen seid und ihr seht, dass da irgendwie Leute, denen ihr grundsätzlich positiv äh
gesinnt seid ein Testzentrum betreiben, dann könnt ihr da ruhig hingehen, weil die Kompensation protest, die ist schon relativ großzügig. Ja, das heißt nicht, dass man damit einen Anfangsinvest
sofort wieder hinkriegt und auch wenn man monatliche Miete hat und so, ne? Aber ich würde vorsichtig sagen, wenn ihr
zum Beispiel jetzt in die Außengastronomie geht, die er geöffnet hat und dafür einen Schnelltest macht, dann hat das Schnelltestzentrum an eurem Besuch am Ende mehr Profit als die Gastronomin, die ihr besucht.
Das ist, glaube ich, unstrittig.
Ja, gut. Lässt sich im Einzelnen immer, immer schwierig einschätzen, ne, äh weiß ja auch nicht, was da für Personalkosten noch dazukommen.
Er kommt darauf an, welche Restaurants man geht, ne? Aber so fünfzehn Euro Profit äh lässt du äh selten im Restaurant, weil du meistens vielleicht sogar unter fünfzehn Euro überhaupt da isst.
Das ist schon äh es ist auch, also ich ich bin ja selber zwiegespalten, weil ich find's auch ganz gut, dass es jetzt niedrigschwerig diese Angebote gibt, aber ich ich so wähle meine Testzentren auch mit Bedacht,
So, weil was sich an einigen sehe, also ganz abgesehen davon, was sie alle für eine, für eine Software da betreiben, äh habe ich dann schon den den Eindruck, also es es ist einfach sehr, sehr,
naheliegend und verlockend für diese Testzentren in Zeiten der Langeweile einfach die äh alle paar Minuten,
wegzuwerfen und zu hinzuschreiben, sie hätten Micky Maus getestet, ne? Das ist einfach in in vielen Regionen zu zu einfach und deswegen gibt's da jetzt auch diese,
in Millionenhöhe. Das war schon klar.
Gut, aber eigentlich wollten wir ja über Netzpolitik reden, oder? War das nicht der Titel der Sendung, an dem wir uns immer ganz streng äh zu halten haben? Und sonst gibt's Klopper äh in den Kommentaren.
Stimmt, Entschuldigung. Feedback, wir hatten Feedback von Enno, wir hatten über die Colonia Pipeline gesprochen, also diese
Pipeline in den USA, die einige Tage den Betrieb eingestellt hat. Enno schrieb mir, hallo Linus, jetzt gehe ich mal unter die Leserbriefschreiber, höre gerade NLP, deine Bemerkungen.
Zum Colonia Pipeline Angriff und muss an einer Stelle widersprechen. Sie haben nicht die Pipeline ausgeschaltet, weil sie kein BILING mehr machen konnten.
Das ist eine Unterstellung. Der, soweit ich recherchieren konnte von Zielen. Äh die.
Soweit ich äh sehen, recherchieren konnte von CNN in die Welt gesetzt wurde und sich von dort weiterverbreitet hat. Es stimmt
soweit bekannt geworden, nur die Rechner im Rechnungswesen betroffen
waren, die verantwortlichen standen vor der Situation, dass einige Systeme von mywere befallen waren und man nicht weiß, wie viele noch. Um die Daten potenziell befallener Rechner vor Verschlüsselung zu retten.
Werden dann halt
alle Systeme heruntergefahren. Diese Strategie scheint Standardreaktion auf Rancunway-Angriffe zu sein. Kürzlich ist zum Beispiel die TU Berlin genauso verfahren alle Systeme beinhaltet in diesem Fall das Abschalten der Pipelines, die mit viel digitaler Mess- und Regelungstechnik bestückt,
ist. Normalerweise sind solche Systeme von anderen Systemen wie der Buchhaltung getrennt, aber ich vermute, dass die Verantwortlichen,
lichen sich dessen nicht sicher waren. Wäre es zu einem Spil mit entsprechender Umweltkatastrophe gekommen, hätten die Betreiber sich vorhalten lassen müssen, dass ihr System nicht
sicher vor solchen Angriffen geschützt worden ist. So können sie einfach sagen, ihnen sei passiert, was vielen anderen auch gerade passiert und sie haben ihr Bestes getan, um Schlimmeres zu verhindern. Liebe Grüße, Eno. Ja
Also hat er, hat, hast du Recht, ähm die,
in dem Moment, wo du, also sowieso sind solche Systeme nicht getrennt. Ja, wenn die getrennt wären.
Dann hieße, dass er irgendwie, dass den ganzen Tag Leute an dem einen Computer gucken müssen, wie viel Öl wohin geliefert wurde und das irgendwie noch einmal abtippen müssen woanders hin. Es,
es wird immer grob gesagt, ja, wir haben eine tolle Firewall, die trennt diese Systeme. Ähm also Operation Technology und Information Technology, aber das.
Ist natürlich nicht so. Die müssen ja irgendwie miteinander reden. Man hat ja eben eine vernetzte Produktion. Dazwischen sind von mir aus irgendwie groß angelegte Firewalls, aber es ist ähm.
Klar und richtig und deswegen danke ich auch für die Korrektur, dass man natürlich in einem solchen Fall sichergehen muss, dass der Schaden nicht noch größer wird und ähm.
Den ganzen Krempel neu aufzusetzen nach einem breiten ist,
in der Regel unumgänglich. Jetzt ist das natürlich auch so, üblicherweise wird bei solchen Angriff eben erst die Rechnerflotte übernommen, also man verschafft sich irgendwie.
Active Directory Rechte und rollt dann die auf verschiedene äh auf auf alle Systeme aus und muss eben auch das Ziel haben, alles
Platz zu reißen, was man in die Finger kriegt und da sich hinzustellen und zu sagen, die Pipeline ist aber hinter einer Firewall, wäre äh sicherlich ein ein großes äh Risiko gewesen. Insofern.
Ähm danke für die Korrektur. Wir haben über schon mal viel gesprochen, da mache ich auch nochmal den Link rein, wo wir äh über.
Hier, wie heißen sie? Gesprochen haben.
Genau, also das ist halt ein wiederkehrendes Ding und meine die Abhängigkeiten solcher Systeme sind einfach,
vielfältig. Und selbst wenn man eine Architektur plant, die möglichst tiefe Gräben zieht, müssen sie an irgendeiner Stelle ja dann doch übersprungen werden. Und äh insofern kann ich das sehr gut nachvollziehen in diesem Fall, dass die erstmal gesagt haben, alle
alles äh alles ausschalten, weil wir halt potenziell,
in diesem Moment so schnell überhaupt nicht einschätzen können, wie groß das Problem noch noch wird und weiß der Geier, vielleicht haben sie ja auch ein sehr viel größeres Problem auch noch verhindert und dann
ist das halt so. Man muss halt dafür sorgen, dass man im Prinzip so resiliente Systeme
die vielleicht auch regelmäßig äh dahingehend getestet werden, dass sie quasi so jederzeit,
ähm wenn man sagt, okay, zu diesem Zeitpunkt wussten wir, da war noch alles okay, wir machen jetzt einen Rollback dahin und äh die Daten, die äh potenziell dann verloren gehen, die sind irgendwie auf eine andere Art und Weise ausgeleitet worden vorher, dass man die wieder reinsinken kann
wo sicher ist, dass da kein Code äh dabei ist.
Das ist, glaube ich, so ein bisschen der Auftrag für Software und Sicherheitsarchitektur so für die nächste Dekade, solche Systeme äh so zu bauen, dass man das mehr oder weniger vom Reißbrett äh mit einbringen kann.
Also das ist tatsächlich das äh der Fehler, den die meisten machen. Ich bin ja auch beruflich regelmäßig mit solchen Fällen.
Betraut, hm, dass die, also für die Feder zusammenfassen mit, du hast zwar ein Backup, aber kein Wiederanlaufkonzept.
Sehr schlecht, weil du hast ja eine sehr komplexe Infrastruktur, häufig fehlt den Leuten auch wirklich einfach einen ad hoc Überblick über die gegenseitigen Abhängigkeiten.
Das heißt, sie können nicht sagen, welche Möglichkeiten hast du von Bereich A im Bereich B zu kommen? Oder wo läuft da vielleicht doch noch was zusammen
Hacks gehen ja immer um die Ecke, das heißt ne, es ist nie der direkte Zugriff, sondern was weiß ich. Dann hat eben dieser.
Ade Admin auch Möglichkeiten, den anderen Bereich zu administrieren und schon sind deine ganzen Firewalls äh obsolet. Und,
was du gerade ansprichst, ist nämlich, also bei dem Wiederanlaufkonzept, die Basis davon ist eben eigentlich, sagen wir mal, Systeme.
Und nutzt Daten getrennt wieder herzustellen.
Also in in einem Unique-System oder Linuxen und so ist das schon relativ.
Gut so vorgesehen, ne? Du du installierst halt dieses Paket.
Dass äh die Software hat ihre Nutzdaten dann an dieser Stelle, sodass du,
eigentlich, wenn du dich kurz mit der Software auseinandergesetzt hast, relativ zielsicher
so 'n Backup machen kannst, dass du sagst OK die Nutzdaten sind hier und alles was ich brauche ist was weiß ich in mit diesen Paketen und dann kannst du dir mit halt 'n Playbook machen, was sagt setz mir bitte den Server
mal aus einem Backup neu auf und das läuft durch. Aber diesen.
Automatisierungsgrad ähm erreichen viele Unternehmen erst dann, wenn sie einmal,
von einer betroffen waren, dann alles neu bauen müssen und dabei dann anfangen zum Beispiel mit oder anderen äh Systemen, die diese playbooks anzulegen,
und äh äh die entsprechenden Backups zu machen.
Ja und es hat nicht nur eine Frage von solchen Systemen äh Werkzeugen, sondern ist halt auch,
eine Frage der Software, Kultur, also Software muss natürlich dann auch so gebaut sein, dass sie.
Dass sie mit solchen Prinzipien klarkommt und ja, das ist, glaube ich, ein Lernprozess, wie.
Security an sich ein Lernprozess war, wenn man sich anschaut wie vor zwanzig Jahren, noch Systeme ausgeliefert und ans Netz gehängt worden.
Ja oder auch heute, Luca.
Ja. Jetzt hast du das Wort gesagt. Ähm.
Ja klar, ne, also selbstverständlich kommt das auch nicht bei jedem sofort an und äh und das ist eigentlich auch so eine Erkenntnis, dass bestimmte Fehler,
wenn sie denn generell möglich sind, auch immer wieder gemacht werden und dass das eben
technisch auch eine Frage des richtigen Fortschritts ist in der Informatik im zunehmendem Maße dafür zu sorgen, dass bestimmte Fehler gar nicht erst gemacht werden können. Also nur mal so,
einfaches Beispiel früher war so Programmabstürze durch falsche Speicherzugriffe so einfach,
der Klassiker schlechthin, ja? Und äh jetzt geht's in zunehmendem Maße natürlich in Richtung Programmiersprachen benutzen, wo so ein Fehler gar nicht mehr auftreten kann,
natürlich noch viele andere, die auftreten können und die treten ja dann auch
schiebt sich immer wieder so ein bisschen nach vorne so, aber im Prinzip muss man das eben auch systemweit denken, ne, so wie setze ich eine Anwendung auf. Und dann ist der erste Schritt ist, okay und jetzt sorgen wir als allererstes sorgen wir erst mal dafür, dass die
Tour ausgerollt wird, damit wir jederzeit zu jedem Zeitpunkt irgendwie gehen können und den Datenstand,
dem Moment äh uns wieder reinsünken et cetera und dass die Software auf jeden Fall da ist und das
dass die aktuellen Daten auch nicht verloren gehen. So und das ist sozusagen der erste Schritt in dem Moment, wo du überhaupt erstmal sagst, ich baue jetzt hier eine neue App. Und das, das ist irgendwas, was wir in zehn Jahren einfach haben werden und was heutzutage einfach noch nicht da ist.
Darfst du was zu Luca-App sagen.
Christian hat uns geschrieben. Neulich war ich beruflich in Hamburg unterwegs, wo die Inzedenz derzeit unter dreißig liegt. Natürlich habe ich gleich die Gelegenheit genutzt und nach über vierzehn Monaten mal wieder offline geshoppt
etwas wonach ich überhaupt gar keinen Drang verspüre lieber Christian, aber äh wenn es für dich äh wichtig ist, vor Galeria Kaufhof Karstadt,
ist zwei Schlangen. Eine Schlange mit Luca-App, eine Schlange ohne Luca-App. Natürlich habe ich mich
in die letztere eingereiht. Als ich an der Reihe war, wurde nach meinem Ausweis gefragt und Name, Anschrift, Telefonnummer notiert. Der Mitarbeiter tippte diese Daten in sein Tablet ein.
Beiläufig viel mehr auf, dass er meine Daten in die Luca-App einspeiste.
Nach dem Check-In ging ich dann recht schnell in die vierte Etage, kaufte zwei neue Jeans und verließ das Geschäft wieder ein Checkout, erfolgte nicht. Ich denke, dieses Beispiel zeigt,
die Nutzlosigkeit der,
Luca App auf. Hier muss nicht mehr das viel zitierte Beispiel des Zoos herhalten. Was würde nun also passieren, wenn jemand tatsächlich positiv getestet und angeben würde, er wäre am gleichen Tag wie ich bei Galeria einkaufen gewesen,
Möglicherweise war diese Person im ersten, zweiten Stock unterwegs und ist mir nie begegnet, möglicherweise kam diese Person erst im Geschäft an, als ich schon lange weg war.
Einen Check-Out gab es für mich ja nicht. Würde man auf Grundlage dieser wackeligen Datenbasis nun Quarantäne oder selbst Isolation für mich anordnen?
Sicherer fühle ich mich durch den Einsatz der Luka-App nun nicht gerade. In meinen Augen ist das alles sehr viel Bürokratie und sehr wenig Zusatznutzen. Über die Verwendung meiner Daten wurde ich natürlich auch nicht aufgeklärt,
Weder hat man mir eine Datenschutzerklärung ausgehändigt,
mich durch Aushang der oder mündlichen Hinweis auf eine Fundstelle verwiesen. Hätte ich nicht genauer hingesehen, wüsste ich nicht einmal, dass meine Daten nun auf dem Lukaser gelandet sind. Ja.
Und zu so einem Scheiß ermutigen diese Leute ja auch äh die Locations. Es ist.
Es ist sowieso also in Galeria Kaufhof ist so ein schönes Beispiel für einen riesen Laden.
Wo und wo niemand jemals sagen wird, diese Daten interessieren uns. Das kannste,
einfach sein lasse. Ich habe hier auch heute ist nachher eigentlich zitieren, nochmal die Aussage von einem äh Gesundheitsamt
Leiter, der sagte so, also ist ja schön und gut mit den ganzen
Schwachstellen in Luca, ne? Aber ich sehe unser Gesundheitsamt nicht bedroht, weil die Daten rufen wir eh nicht ab. So, das äh scheint dann doch sehr.
Ehrlich zu sein. Dann haben wir noch einen eine Mail bekommen, die sich so ein bisschen mit Sommers und Luca auseinandersetzt. Sommers wissen wir, dieses äh System, das.
Ostdeutschland oder mit deutschen Mitteln auch entwickelt wurde und bei der Ebola äh Epidemiebekämpfung.
Sehr erfolgreich zum Einsatz gekommen ist und dass in Deutschland aber bei weitem nicht alle
Gesundheitsämter nutzen. Jetzt sollen sie da sollen sie dazu gezwungen werden und da gibt es aber dann natürlich auch eine Arbeitskultur, die sich dem ein wenig versperrt. Von diesen
und gleichzeitig ist, wir haben aber eine direkte Sommermassanbindung ja das Hauptargument von Luca.
Uns wird also geschrieben. Ich arbeite in der IT einer Kommunalverwaltung. Ich bin zuständig für verschiedene Projekte, unter anderem der Betreuung der Gesundheitsamt-Software,
und in diesen Zusammenhang komme ich auch mit dem mit den Themen Sommers, surf net und Luca in Berührung.
Zunächst vorweg, die Medienberichte nach den Sommers flächendeckend seit Monaten installiert und im Einsatz sei, sind allesamt.
Gelogen. Steht hier. Ich würde sagen unwahr. Ich weiß, mindestens von unserem Landkreis.
Als auch noch von mehreren anderen Kolleginnen in anderen Kreisen, dass die Installation und Umsetzung oftmals in einem weiten Spektrum zwischen kurz vor der Installation und ja, wir planen das auch irgendwann steckt.
Hintergrund der Medienberichte ist vermutlich eine Aussage,
zum Beispiel der Landesregierung auf eine Anfrage der Landkreise nach der Förder an die Installation und Umsetzung geknöpft wurden.
Und hier haben einfach mehrere Landkreise, inklusive meinem gesagt,
Sommers als alleinige Software zur Verfügung einzusetzen entgegen der Faktenlage. Die Situation mit der mit der Arbeit mit Surf Net sieht ebenso desaströs aus. Obgleich dies die Grundlage für die Umsetzung der Integration,
Luca-App darstellt. Zu Luca. Es gab unzählige Beratungen mit den Verantwortlichen bei uns im Hause. Die Situation stellt sich bei uns wie vermutlich auch bei vielen anderen.
Kommunen wie folgt da. Seit Wochen. Die Hausleitung macht Druck, weil es politischen Druck aus der Wirtschaft gibt,
zu öffnen und Luca ja bekanntlich der Heilsbringer sei. Das Gesundheitsamt sieht keine Probleme.
Und will Luca, weil dann ist ja alles leichter ohne Papier. Unbequeme Bedenkenträgerin.
Wurden innerhalb weniger Beratung immer weniger in die Gespräche und Prozesse eingebunden und sind dann angewiesen die Voraussetzungen für die Integration entgegen aller vorgebrachten Bedenkungen zu schaffen.
An dieser Stelle vielen Dank für eure großartige Arbeit, sowohl im CCC als auch im Podcast. Aktuell geht ein Schriftverkehr zwischen,
Land und Hausleitung herum.
Bei der der Landesdatenschützer mit der äh Landesregierung clash.
Bislang konnten wir die Einführung bremsen, allerdings wird es zunehmend schwerer. Und ich finde das, das sehr bezeichnend, ne? Also je, je weniger die Leute tatsächlich mit den Daten arbeiten müssen, umso mehr,
singen die dir äh stolz das Lied von Luca, ne? Und wenn du dann mal jemanden fragst, so, habt ihr euch die Daten mal angeschaut, sind die brauchbar? Nein,
würdet ihr die abrufen? Nein. Ne? Total, totaler äh totaler Quatsch, der da stattfindet. Und es ist wirklich äh sehr, sehr ärgerlich, dass dass diese dass es.
Denen gelingt.
Entgegen aller Kompetenz in den Gesundheitsämtern entgegen aller Kompetenz im Bereich der IT, im Bereich der IT-Sicherheit
diesen Mist den Leuten aufs Auge zu drücken. Es ist wirklich eine Katastrophe und noch mal dabei daran erinnert
Das ist ein privatwirtschaftliches Unternehmen, das ein Jahreslizenzen an die Länder verkauft und damit Millionen verdient und irgendwie einsatzbereit ist der Mist nirgendwo zu sehen.
Und selbst wenn er's wäre, würde er äh nicht nicht viel bringen, wie wir an diesem Galerie Kaufhof äh Ding ja auch schon gesehen haben.
Ja, das ist das ist so das Grundproblem und ich meine, das
tauchte jetzt hier in diesem Kommentar auch schon auf, ne? Das Wort in anderer Form auch schon öfter gebracht. Es ist so dieser Heilsbringer, ne? Es ist so dieses gucke mal hier, ne, das können wir schön in die Kamera halten
und alle haben das Gefühl, das was getan wird,
Und das ist natürlich äh oft in der Politik und in der Gesellschaft so, dass sich alle so an so etwas klammern, so nach dem Motto ja, aber Luca. So
Als als ob da mit irgendwas gelöst wäre und führt auch zu den Absurdesten Situationen in diesen Restaurants und es wird vor allem ohnehin weitgehend ignoriert.
Absolut, also ja genau, es wird glücklicherweise äh agiert dann eben auch die Gastronomie
ähnlich und sagt komm ey lass den Scheiß sein. Es ist was,
irgendwie auch auch in dieser Mail, dachte ich mir so, ich habe mich jetzt nicht sicherer gefühlt wegen Luca, ne? Ja, natürlich fühlst du dich nicht sicher wegen Luca, weil Luca,
ändert auch nichts daran, dass du dich in dem Moment infizierst oder nicht, ne. Maske aufziehen, geimpft sein, ist tausendmal geiler als irgendeine bescheuerte App zu äh na ja okay, lassen wir das. Ähm.
Ich wollte mal was Positives erzählen, Tim.
Kommt jetzt einfach das Konzept hier brechen.
Nee, ich würde, ich würde sogar sagen, es also ähm,
Ja, vielleicht, also ich weiß nicht, ob's für eine gute Nachricht reicht, aber ich war gestern in einer, bei einer TV-Aufzeichnung
ja? Einer äh eines relativ neuen Sendeformates, das im im ZDF und auf ZDF Neo und im.
Im YouTube kommt. Und ich beklage ja durchaus die.
Debattenkultur, die wir so in diesem Land äh und in den sozialen Netzwerken haben.
Weil es hier den wenigsten Leuten noch irgendwie darum geht,
ne, ein Thema zu ergründen oder zu erörtern, sondern vielen Menschen einfach nur noch darum geht, halt möglichst einfache äh Wahrheiten rauszuhauen und wir haben riesige Probleme, was,
die also was Angriffe und Diskriminierung angeht, was die Verbreitung von Unwahrheiten angeht und wir.
Dass wir spalten unsere ganze Gesellschaft, ja? Obwohl wir mit dem Internet ein Tool haben, dass.
Auf jeden Fall eine Grundvoraussetzung dafür ist, das zu überkommen. Ja, jetzt gibt's also eine Reihe an unschönen Phänomenen. Wir müssen uns irgendwie darüber hinaus,
entwickeln und ich äh es liegt auch nicht nur am Internet, ne? Also ich finde besonders tragisches Phänomen sind ja echt diese Talkshows, in die du.
In der Regel hingehst mit deinen paar Talking Points und wie besonders geil bei Anne Will oder Maischberger oder wie diese ganzen Sendungen heißen. Ich ihr redet jetzt auch wieder jemand der keine Ahnung hat von diesen Sendungen, weil ich die seit
Jahren schon nicht mehr gucke, ne. Wer gesagt, dass ich bei Markus Lanzner aus,
mache, der macht auch eine Ausnahme bei mir, weil das ist ja die einzige Sendung, in die ich ab und zu mal eingeladen werde. Ähm und da finde ich auch äh sage ich mal, die Gesprächskultur halbwegs noch,
ansprechend. Ich habe aber jetzt bei dieser Sendung, wo ich jetzt war, die hat den Titel dreizehn Fragen und die hat,
die machen das so, du hast also quasi sechs Gäste waren wir.
Eine äh prominente Dragqueen, Maja el wat äh von.
Diana zur Löwen, eine ähm Influencerin.
Einen Model und äh Influencerin und Hans Block, das ist einer der Regisseure von,
Ja, auch übrigens ein Film, den ich bei dieser Gelegenheit nochmal empfehlen möchte. Und der Hans hat mir gestern erzählt, dass man den jetzt in der Mediathek der Bundeszentrale für politische Bildung auch schauen kann. Deswegen haben wir den Link nochmal,
auch in den sehr, sehr zu empfehlen.
Was ist das für ein Film?
Der handelt von den Menschen, die die Content-Moderation bei Facebook machen.
Okay, oh je.
Also wo der Teil, sage ich mal, der, wo Sache, wo Inhalte gemeldet werden oder einen Algorithmus, die als verdächtig gefiltert hat und dann müssen Menschen draufschauen und das ähm ja, verifizieren, wegmachen,
und ähm dass der der der Staat dieser ganzen,
Recherche die da war eben da gab's einen Fall vor mehreren Jahren wo in ich glaube das war Kanada ein Missbrauchsvideo auf Facebook gepostet wurde und viral gegangen ist.
Ja, also quasi diese diese Content Moderation versagt hat. Und dadurch sind die beiden Regisseure auf die Frage gekommen, hör mal, wie funktioniert das eigentlich? Und haben dann festgestellt, dass das eben.
Menschen gibt, die da äh sitzen,
und äh das äh machen müssen. Und die sitzen in äh in diesem Fall,
Manila, an dem weltweit größten Outsourcing Standort für Content Moderation. Das sind quasi, was die herausgefunden haben, Hans Block und Moritz Riesewiek äh ist auch tatsächlich neu gewesen,
Ja, also das war einfach nicht bekannt. Und die haben's dann geschafft, mit den,
diesen Content-Moderatorinnen zu sprechen über ihre Arbeit und das, was sie da sehen. Ähm sehr zu empfehlen.
Mit denen waren mit diesen sechs Leuten und ich war also diese fünf Leute und ich waren jetzt da und die Sendung funktioniert folgendermaßen. Ähm die haben irgendwie so eine grobe Hauptfrage. In diesem Fall war das, brauchen die sozialen Netzwerke mehr Regulierung.
Zur ähm um Hate Speech entgegen zu treten. Und das Spielfeld ist jetzt so aufgebaut, dass du.
Sagen wir mal, äh zur Vereinfachung, sage ich jetzt mal, man steht sich gegenüber und es gibt mehrere Felder
Ja und es waren jetzt drei Personen, die sagten, wir denken, dass es notwendig ist, hier mehr staatlich einzugreifen. Und es waren drei Personen, die sagen, wir denken, es ist nicht nötig, hier noch mehr.
Staatlich einzugreifen. Und.
Die einen stehen quasi in der gelben Ecke, die anderen in der äh grünen Ecke und jetzt kommen verschiedene Fragen,
die dann der Moderator in unserem Fall auch ein,
denke ich, äh inzwischen sehr bekannter Moderator, so ZDF, Aspekte und so. Da kennt man den Herr ähm immer mit ja, ein bisschen,
anspruchsvolleren oder hochqualitativeren Formaten stellt dann eben unterschiedliche Fragen,
und die werden dann so in der Gruppe diskutiert, ne? Also spricht dann jetzt, was weiß ich, einzelne Personen an, dann können andere entgegnen. Und du kannst als Teilnehmerin eben, wenn die Gegenseite jetzt etwas sagt, halt einen Schritt auf sie zugehen.
Und ähm so
werden dann verschiedene Ideen erört hat, ne? Und ähm dann kommst du am Ende zur zu einem Kompromiss. Und diese oder
Das Ziel der Sendung ist ein Kompromiss zu erlangen, ja, wie auch immer der aussehen sollte. Und ich habe eigentlich auch gedacht, naja, also ehrlich gesagt glaube ich nicht, dass man,
mich hier zu irgendeinem Kompromiss hinkriegt, so, ne?
Aber was ich an dieser Sendung so toll fand, ist, sie befördert ist, das Ziel der Sendung, einfach die Sendungsmechanik ist nicht
dass du da hingehst und die anderen irgendwie fertigmachst. Und ähm sehr bemerkenswert die äh Journelle hat in dem,
hat in der Sendung dann gesagt so, sie würde eine sie fänden es nicht schlecht, wenn man sich in sozialen Netzwerken mit Ausweis registrieren müsste.
Und dann haben wir eine haben wir Gegenargumente angebracht und sie hat von ihrer Position Abstand genommen und hat gesagt,
Das äh habe ich nicht. Ähm bedacht und insofern diese Forderung äh,
vor der distanziere ich mich jetzt wieder, ne? Stell dir mal vor, so etwas würde bei bei Anne Will passieren.
Da würden Pauken und Trompeten würden alle sagen, watt, Alter, wer bist du denn? Du kommst hier in die Sendung und du du lässt dich auf einmal von einem, von einem anderen Argument überzeugen, du hast verloren, du bist die Loserin, geh nach Hause, dann wirst du am nächsten Tag auf Spiegel Online verarscht oder so, ne?
Und in diesem Format wird das aber befördert, ja? Das ähm und und es gab's natürlich, ich habe jetzt das als ein Extrembeispiel genommen, weil das äh,
weil sie das auch sehr offensiv äh gesagt hat. So, okay, ich bin, ich bin überzeugt, ich äh von eurem Argument diese Forderung äh stelle ich nicht mehr auf. Und das fand ich ähm das ist in sehe ich in diesen Fernsehformaten nicht.
Ja? Und das finde ich wirklich sehr zielführend. Ich ich wünsche dieser Sendung viel Erfolg und ähm.
Einfluss, dass wir mal wegkommen von diesen Talkshow Arenen, in denen irgendwie die Gladiatoren immer wieder die gleichen reingekippt werden, äh um um um sich um sich gegenseitig irgendwas an den Kopf zu werfen
Und das äh hat mich dann doch sehr beeindruckt dieses Format. Deswegen wollte ich dafür werben.
Ist ja auch vor allem mal wirklich was, wo man eine Kamera braucht. Oder wo die Kamera sinnvoll ist.
Ja, genau, genau, also das auch noch, ne? Ähm und äh weil du eben dieses Spielfeld hast, das also ich mich interessierte daran jetzt eher so diese die die dass die Mechanik der Sendung.
Einfach nur dir sagt so, übrigens, du kannst hier, ne,
die anderen zugehen und es gibt erst die Fragen runter und dann gibt's die Kompromissrunde und dann äh na, müsst ihr mal irgendwie,
aufeinander klar kommen. Und was hier natürlich noch ganz spannend war, war, dass natürlich alle sich darüber einig waren, dass irgendwie dieser ganze Hate im Internet nicht wünschenswert ist.
Und das man dann halt Meinungsverschiedenheiten darüber gab, wie ähm,
Problemen zu begegnen ist. Und das ist überhaupt schon mal der, der das war schon mal der erste Punkt, dass man das in der Sendung überhaupt hingekriegt hat
weil wenn ich jetzt äh sagen wir mal in eine der bekannten TV-Sendungen gehen würde, ne, dann dann müsste ich mich ja,
mit einer solchen Position die ganze Zeit rechtfertigen, ob ich denn den Hate in Ordnung finde, der ähm,
anderen Menschen da im Internet äh insbesondere natürlich äh ne, sind ja immer die gleichen, ne? Irgendwie von dem Schmalen,
Bereich der Sexualität abweichende oder von dem schmalen,
deutsch definierten Bereich abweichende äh Mitglieder unserer Gesellschaft, die sich dann allen Scheiß anhören müssen, ne. Und mit denen willst du dich natürlich nicht gemein machen und dieses in die Ecke gedrängt zu werden, hat da halt nicht stattgefunden. Und fand ich wirklich beeindruckend.
Ja, das das durch eine einfache Mechanik in dieser Talkshow, die es ja nicht ist, sondern die Show,
das hinzukriegen, so 'ne Kultur herbeizuführen, fand ich super. Ich weiß nicht, ob das bei allen Themen so gut funktioniert, ich weiß auch nicht, ob man das wöchentlich machen könnte mit den Themen, die irgendwie was weiß ich, bei,
den typischen äh Politarenen stattfinden, aber überhaupt mal zu sagen, hier bei uns geht's darum, sich näher zu kommen und nicht äh sich gegenseitig mitm äh Holzhammer auf den Kopf zu hauen und daraus ein funktionierendes Format äh wachsen zu lassen,
finde ich beeindruckend.
Wollte ich mal loswerden. Kann man irgendwann gucken. Weiß noch nicht genau, wann die Sendung kommt, aber ähm gibt natürlich auch andere und äh bin mal gespannt, ob wir vielleicht das doch noch schaffen, äh die Kurve zu kriegen, was die Debattenkultur in Deutschland angeht.
Wann kommt denn die Sendung raus?
Weiß ich nicht ganz genau, die haben so, also die haben jetzt mehrere Sendetermine mir gesagt äh und aber wann diese spezifische kommt, äh es ist noch nicht äh genau gesichert.
Mhm. Ja, bin ich
Bin ich gespannt, wie das funktioniert. Ich äh kannte das auch noch nicht, werde mir das mal angucken. Ähm ist auf jeden Fall mal eine interessante Einsatz von von Fernsehen. Und äh das ist ja auch was äh auch was wert. Fandst du die also die Auswahl der Personen.
War gut.
Ja selbstverständlich, ne? Die haben ja alle, also ähm die haben ja alle ihre Erfahrungen und ihre Kompetenzen gehabt. Ja, die Redaktion hat da denke ich, eine sehr äh gute Arbeit geleistet, ne, also hm äh wenn jetzt mal schaust, die,
Also äh.
Elektra Pain ist 'ne Dragqueen, kannst du dir natürlich vorstellen, was die an Kommentaren sich angucken kann, na? Dann.
Ist ein türkisches Model mit äh teilweise ja auch äh.
Ja, Aktionen oder so, die eben offenbar Menschen provozieren, ja? Äh also völlig lächerlich, dass sie sie provozieren, obwohl sie dann natürlich auch entsprechende äh,
durchaus ihre Erfahrung hat mit mit irgendwelchen Kommentaren und Leuten, die sich da Fake-Accounts betreiben und so weiter.
Hans eben als der äh Regisseur dieses Films und der Recherche äh ne, mit einem Einblick in die Content-Moderation wie niemand anders. Die,
Diana zur Löwen ist äh wie gesagt irgendwie auf ich glaube Instagram und ähm primär glaube ich Instagram aktiv, sehr jung,
Frau, na? Große Reichweite ähm und äh hat hauptsächlich keine politischen oder wenig politische Themen, aber wenn sie in dem Bereich geht, spitzt sie natürlich auch die Veränderung.
Gerade wenn's in in den feministischen Bereich geht und äh die Maja als äh Juristin bei ist ja auch die Kompetenz unbestritten und äh insofern denke ich, dass das ähm.
Auch von der Redaktion eine gelungene Auswahl war, um das Thema.
Gezielt zu erörtern. Ich weiß jetzt natürlich auch nicht, wenn das jetzt um Überwachung gegangen wäre und auf der anderen Seite hätte, äh was weiß ich, äh
Horst Seehofer gestanden, dann weiß ich auch nicht, wie gut
das noch funktioniert hätte, ne. Ähm aber dem Format sollte also überhaupt diese die Spielmechanik einer politischen Diskussionsschau überhaupt mal anzugehen.
Halte ich für den den schon den genialen Schachzug hier.
Gut. Kommen wir zum nächsten Thema. Ich bin ja so froh, dass wir das Luca-Thema schon durch.
Bin auch froh, dass er echt nicht mehr über Luca reden müssen. Ähm ganz kurz, also nur, es ist, also du wir haben ja die die Sendung mit Markus rausgehauen, dann hatte er direkt noch gefunden, dass quasi in dem Versuch.
CSV zu fixen. Luca einen neuen,
eingeführt hat, der dazu führt, dass dass dieses Backend-System quasi abstürzt. Also jetzt konntest du dein neuer Check-In hat jetzt nicht dafür gesorgt, dass du deren Excel gehackt hast.
Sondern dass einfach den Server abschmiert.
Vielleicht kurz so ein bisschen Kontext mit irgendwie berichtete. Es ging dadrum
Datenübernahme im Gesundheitsamt über so einen äh Datei-Import, wo wir halt gesagt haben, okay Leute, ihr äh schaut nicht, was ihr für Daten rausgebt und es ist möglich, da äh Daten reinzubringen, die dann das äh Excel ausm Tritt bringen.
Beim Import und dann haben sie reagiert, indem sie jetzt versucht haben, das zu filtern und dadurch, dass sie jetzt versucht haben, etwas zu filtern, haben sie sich wieder das nächste Problem eingetreten.
Also erstmal haben sie sich das Problem eingetreten, dass es eine ganze Reihe Buchstaben, die im deutschen dann doch auch gebräuchlich sind, nicht mehr zulassen. Ähm und dann haben sie sich eben einen.
Ein eingehandelt, wo ähm ein Check auf ein auf eine variable des falschen Typs stattfindet und dann schwirrt die ganze Applikation ab. Das heißt, du kannst Gottes jetzt quasi bei dem Export.
Dafür sorgen, dass der, dass diese Luca-App abschmiert mit einem mit einem Fehler und dann kommt halt gar nix mehr, ne? Was die Sache natürlich noch schlimmer macht, weil dann kommen da gar keine Daten mehr raus. Ähm,
dann haben sie, was auch, also wirklich an der du weißt wirklich nicht, ob die wirklich so dermaßen inkompetent sind oder ähm,
Und ich ich fürchte fast eine Kombination aus beiden. Und zwar.
Haben wir ja auch in Lok im Logbuch darüber gesprochen, dass der Fehler unter anderem darin bestand, dass sie in dem Feld für die Postleitzahl.
Alles Mögliche zugelassen haben, also alle Zeichen und auch beliebige Länge, während wir ja wissen, durch Rolf, dass die Postleitzahl in Deutschland fünf,
Ziffern sind. Punkt. Die zu heißen, ist ähm enorm einfach. Du guckst einfach an allen fünf Stellen, ob's eine Ziffer ist, schneidest den Rest ab und bist durch, ja? Ähm,
und die CSV Injection wird primär eingeleitet durch das,
Gleichheitszeichen. In diesem Falle. Es gibt von Oversp eine ähm dem Open Web Application Security.
Ich weiß, vergesse immer, wofür das P steht. Aber im Prinzip diese diese standardisierten Empfehlungen zur Sicherheit einer ähm einer Applikation.
Anweisungen, wie man eine CSV injektion verhindert. Da sind eben verschiedene böse Zeichen drin geschildert. Und der Vorwurf war immer, ihr setzt diese Ohrwaspempfehlung,
Empfehlungen nicht um. Und es ist ja nun mal auch richtig, dass sie die nicht umgesetzt haben. Dann haben sie aber jetzt irgendwie der, der Patrick Hennig, der CEO dieses Unternehmens und der,
Heißt der. Äh Markus Bublitz, der.
Begnadete, also ein begnadeter PR-Sprecher. Kannst du wirklich einen einzeln, also wirklich,
wirklich Herz ein besonders gutes schlechtes Beispiel haben dann den Markus vorgeworfen.
Er hätte nicht,
er hätte ihn ja nicht wirklich den Fehler gemeldet, weil jetzt behalte ich fest, Sinn. Der Fehler war nicht nur, dass sie das Gleichheitszeichen zugelassen haben, sondern auch.
Dass sie das Komma zugelassen haben. Und.
In einer CSV, also wenn also um das nochmal zu erklären, dass Dateiformat heißt,
Und das heißt, das Komma separiert Werte.
Und wenn du natürlich dann in ein Feld, ein Komma schreibst, dann muss dieses Komma werden in dem CSV-Format. Ähm.
Genauso wie, wenn du in einem String ein Anführungszeichen setzt. Ja, also da, das ist das, das ist die Tücken des CSV-Formates ist, das Komma und nur das Komma hat den CSV eine echt besondere Bedeutung und deswegen darfst du nicht einfach einen Komma zulassen.
Anführungsstrich hat auch eine besondere Bedeutung, weil damit macht man das dann.
Genau und und in Anführungs und in Anführungsstrichen, weil der äh eben, also ne, der der die.
Und dann haben die sich ernsthaft beschwert.
Bei äh bei Markus Mengengs, dass er ihnen nur gesagt hat, dass sie die Overs-Regel nicht einhalten, während sie ja auch noch die CSV-Regeln nicht einhalten,
und und das haben die denen zum Vorwurf gemacht. Ja, also.
Was heißt denn sie? Escape nicht das Komma. Also, ich meine, sie trennen doch dann, also sie, ach so, sie schreiben einfach die Komma, wenn ein Komma wenn ein Komma im Wert ist, schreiben sie es einfach rein.
Gott und und sie es generell nicht mit Anführungsstrich.
Gar nichts. Und sie haben gesagt, so und und und das, was sie immer meint, wir haben ja einen Overs-Filter
Wenn sie den hatten, was sie immer wieder behaupten, dann hat der halt nur zu Beginn der Zelle geguckt, ob da ein Gleichheitszeichen ist,
Und wenn du aber jetzt in der in der zu Beginn der Zelle in Anführungszeichen Komma hattest und dann gleich als Zeichen oder so, ne, dann hat dieser Filter nicht mehr funktioniert
Also was sie gesagt haben, okay, okay, okay, wir haben das Gleichheitszeichen nicht ordentlich, aber ist ja nur die halbe Geschichte, Markus. Du hast uns ja nur die halbe Geschichte erzählt. Du hast uns ja nicht gesagt, dass wir bei CSV,
Kummer, die ich es gebt haben. So und jetzt kommt's.
Alter, also.
Mehr auszuhalten.
Wie bekloppt sind die denn eigentlich? Das geht doch überhaupt nicht.
Es ist es ist wirklich es ist wirklich nicht wahr. Es ist.
Mann! Das ist doch das habe ich mir doch auf aufm Schulhof seiner Zeit irgendwie reingetrimmt. Mann, das ist doch Sepp, och Gott! Ich fasse es überhaupt nicht!
Es ist wirklich, es ist gar nicht auszuhalten, ja.
Wissen die überhaupt, die wissen überhaupt nicht, was Pasing ist oder so? Also das ist der Begriff, den kennen die gar nicht.
Hochsicherheit, Tim, Hochsicherheit.
Hochsicherheitslösung.
So und das, das und die entblöten sich nicht, weißt du so.
Auch noch auf Twitter zu diskutieren.
Also was sie, was sie hier machen, ne
Die hätten ja sagen können, ah, Scheiße, wir haben umgesetzt, danke für den Hinweis. Jo, äh, haben wir vor vor drei Wochen, als uns das gemeldet wurde, große Fresse gehabt, war falsch, danke schön, Credit, Markus Mengengs, Thema erledigt. Nein, die
die beschuldigen den dann noch auf Twitter, dass sie ja noch viel mehr Fehler gemacht haben. Es ist es ist nicht.
Äh es ist nicht äh vorstellbar. Es geht auf keine Kuhhaut mehr und du fragst dich, gibt's eigentlich niemanden in dem Laden, der zum Beispiel mal diesen feuert, weil der also der schadet dem Laden ja und der CEO,
Patrick Hennig ja auch, ja. Also sie müssten ja wenigstens mal kompetenten Leuten das Reden überlassen. Das ist wirklich aber weißt du, das Schlimme ist, dass diese Strategie ja aufgeht, weil ne.
Um das jetzt hier noch zu erläutern, brauche ich fünf Minuten,
warum das dumm ist, ne. Es gibt natürlich jede, die jemals mit CSV gearbeitet hat, weiß sofort, na ja äh und.
Dass, dass dass man den Fehler machen könnte, ein theoretisches Konstrukt ist, ne, aber dass das ja jede weiß,
wird diese Dateiformat arbeitet. Aber viele Leute verstehen eben gar nichts von dem, was da diskutiert wird und sehen einfach nur, oh krass, äh die haben Vorwürfe äh gegen den Sicherheitsforscher Markus Mengengs,
Unverschämtheit, was was man sich, was der sich bieten lassen muss. Ist wirklich, ist einfach nur eine Frechheit.
Währenddessen weiterhin auf staatliche Kosten riesige Werbekampagnen für diese, für diese App, ja? Und das Schlimme ist ja,
Das Geld, was die damit ja jetzt verdienen, weil das System am Ende nicht wirklich genutzt wird, ne? Ähm das haben die ja, um damit das nächste Projekt zu pitchen irgendwo.
Und zu sagen, kennt er noch Luca? Äh super geil, ey. Da haben wir auch gut hinbekommen. Hier haben wir den nächsten Pitch für zwanzig Millionen. Jetzt scannen wir was weiß ich, äh euch mit dem nächsten Scheiß.
Das ist wirklich deswegen, darf man solchen Leuten kein Geld geben. Spaß übrigens, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, vermuten einige Länder, dass sie vom Bund das Geld zurück
kriegen, was sie für diese Luca ausgegeben haben. Und ich kann nur noch mal die Empfehlung wiederholen, zu sagen, ey, geht dahin.
Euch an, was euch da für ein Murks geliefert wurde äh und geht in Regress. Unglaublich.
Ja, aber Herr Müller wollte das ja bestehen und äh hat sich das ja auch technisch vorher nicht angeschaut, das hat ihn auch nicht interessiert.
Wie gesagt, von einem äh Gesundheitsministerium,
habe ich äh so kolportiert bekommen. Wir müssen uns um die Integrität der IT der Gesundheitsämter wegen Luca keine Sorgen machen. Die Daten benutzt bei uns ohnehin kein Gesundheitsamt. Ich glaube, das ist
tatsächlich die beste Security-Einschätzung zu dieser CSV Injection aus kompetentem Munde.
Wirklich echt. Komm mal nicht ins Kipp. Also,
wirklich echt, also ich meine, da ist jetzt bei mir auch jedes Verständnis jetzt ans Ende gekommen. Also das das geht einfach, das sind das sind keine Anfängerfehler. Das ist irgendwie, ich habe grundsätzlich relativ wenig
Ahnung von Programmieren und von Daten. Das ist so probiert doch mal, macht doch mal was mit Holz.
Es gibt jetzt eine, es gibt jetzt sogar einen ähm einen Fest, in dem äh die quasi in den ähm in diesem äh Fall.
Müsste es vielleicht mal kurz sagen, was dieses ist, weil das.
Haben wir das nicht in der letzten Sendung schon erzählt.
Aber nicht in dieser Sendung. Also ich glaube, in der letzten haben wir es auch nicht gesagt, aber das ist generell so ein Security-Fremwork für Webanwendung, was man berücksichtigen äh sollte.
Also was ist das Open Web Application Security Project. Eine non-profit-organisation, die im Prinzip versucht.
Die häufigsten Fehler in der Programmierung, insbesondere von Webanwendungen.
Ähm zu erläutern und Handreichungen zu geben. Sehr bekannt sind die Overs Top Ten, wo einfach die Top zehn Fehler drinstehen, die Menschen machen.
Ja? Ähm irgendwie und der erste ist Injection, der zweite ist Broken authentication, der dritte ist Sensitive Data Exposur, ne? Und wenn du dir das anschaust, kannst du eigentlich.
Den größeren Teil der Sicherheitslücken, die du da draußen so findest, einfach in diese sagen, ja, das ist irgendwie A äh unsichere Desireli, deserealisierung oder, oder, oder.
Und die geben natürlich auch jeweils die Empfehlungen.
Wo drin steht, wie man den also wie der Fehler zustande kommt und wie man ihn vermeidet. Und bei diesen Overs zur CSV Injection.
Gibt es jetzt ein ähm Fest, wo jemand sagt, übrigens hier steht ähm.
In dem in dem Fall zur CSV Injection stehen nur die bösen Felder in der Zelle. Vielleicht sollte man noch einen Satz hinzuschreiben, dass man sich selbstverständlich auch überlegen muss, was die Zelle ist,
ja? Und also da hat jetzt noch jemand einen.
Quasi hier, es gibt Leute, denen muss man auch das noch erklären. Äh schreibt das mal noch da rein. So ist natürlich dann auch die äh die Community, dass sie natürlich stets bemüht ist, äh sicherzustellen,
dass ähm dass ihre Empfehlung auch verstanden werden.
Tja, sehr unterhaltsam.
Ja, lass uns das Thema beenden.
Ja, kommen wir zum schönen Thema. Ein Kinofilm.
Den wir hier schon mehrmals beworben haben, dessen Filmstart äh glaube ich auch schon relativ,
mehrmals verschoben wurde, so ein bisschen der äh Corona-Pandemie natürlich zum Opfer gefallen.
Und zwar geht es da um den Film Alles ist eins außer der Null. Äh Doktor Computer.
Film, ein Film, über Holland, den Gründer des äh Chaos, Computerclubs, die Anfänge des Chaos, Computerclubs äh spezifisch abdeckend äh mit Schwerpunkt auf ja Perspektiven leben von wow.
Und ähm mündet irgendwann auch in dem in dem,
Chaos, Computerclub der heutigen Zeit, also ne, was ist aus den diesen kleinen Hacker-Treffen-Kongress mit ein paar hundert Leuten heute geworden und auch die politischen ähm Perspektiven und Botschaften, die ich ja auch so besonders ähm.
Ja weitsichtig finde, werde ich ja nicht müde zu betonen, dass halt in der Tuver TXT und,
auch in der Hacker-Ethik eben eine besondere Weitsicht bewiesen wurde, welche Bedeutung, Informatik und Vernetzung in unserer Gesellschaft haben würde und welche.
Sequenzen ähm das haben wird. Ähm.
Ich komme auch ganz kurz in dem Film vor ähm und habe deshalb die große Freude gehabt, schon mal vor längerer Zeit einen Rohschnitt davon zu sehen und bin äh äußerst äh angetan von diesem Film und ähm.
Denke, dass dass man sich freuen kann, denen zu schauen. Jetzt wurde der Kinostart äh auf den neunundzwanzigsten.
Angelegt. Das ist, glaube ich, ein vielversprechendes äh Datum,
Kino-Launch, weil da wird's schön heiß sein
Das heißt, die Inzidenzen werden wahrscheinlich noch schön weit unten sein oder noch weiter unten, als sie jetzt sind und man wird vielleicht in ein Kino gehen dürfen. Die Frage ist, wird man noch in ein Kino gehen wollen bei den Temperaturen, aber soweit ich weiß, sind Kinos ja auch
inzwischen klimatisiert.
Ähm deswegen möchten wir euch darauf aufmerksam machen, dass es diesen Film gibt und dass ihr den sehen wollt.
Ja, das äh kann ich auch empfehlen. Muss ja nicht unbedingt am allerersten Tag sein.
In der ersten Woche hilft dem Film natürlich, ne?
Dem Film und hilft euch unter Umständen auch noch. Dann gibt's doch nicht so eine Begleitaktion.
Ja genau, also wir sind da gerade von Chaos Computerclub in den Planungen.
Für beispielsweise die Premieren und Erstaufführungen ähm.
Begleitung zu schaffen, also beispielsweise ist ganz kurz in meinen Kalender gucken, wo ist das denn?
Am zweiundzwanzigsten Juli 'ne Premiere in Hamburg, im Schanzenpark.
Ach so, übrigens fällt mir ein Tim, es gibt ja auch Open Air Kinos, ne, habe ich ganz vergessen. Das ist nämlich hier Chancenpack ist nämlich, glaube ich, ein Open Air Kino.
Und noch mal eine Woche vorher.
Ja ja genau, das ist irgendwie Premiere oder so, ne? Und es muss ja gar nicht darum gehen, dass du in äh in eine in eine kalte Bude gehst. Es ist ja Zeit, der der. Das heißt, sorry, ganz ganz vergessen. Ist so lange her, dass äh dass ich irgendwo hingehen durfte, ne. Und ähm.
Da gibt es also mehrere Premieren und im Vorführung, wo dann auch Leute aus dem Chaos ähm an Ort und Stelle sind und dann
beispielsweise nach dem Film noch ein bisschen darüber sprechen oder vor dem Film, ne
oder vielleicht noch, je nachdem wie das ist, der lokale Chaos, Computerclub, noch ein Schunk äh serviert. Äh was ich, was ich eben, ne, ermöglichen lässt. Da wird sind wir grade.
In der Planung und da glaube ich kann man, kann man sicherlich erstens 'n guten Film sehen, zweitens mit guten Leuten in Kontakt kommen und das sollte gefeiert werden.
Ja, kann ich auch nur empfehlen.
Ja, ansonsten ist noch zu sagen, Chaos, Computerclub wird hier dieses Jahr vierzig.
Das ist äh co inzidiert natürlich dann hier auch nochmal und ähm das ist alles sehr.
Spannend. Und wenn ich mich nicht täusche das musst du mir sagen Tim, jetzt sich doch in diesem Jahr auch der Todestag, oder?
Also der jährt sich in jedem Jahr, aber.
Von wow. Ja, äh das äh fällt aufs was war das? Das war der ah der neunundzwanzigste Juli.
Ja. Ist genau zwanzig Jahre später.
Von daher dürfte dieser Termin ähm ganz strategisch gewählt äh äh worden sein, genau. Oh Mann, nicht schlecht. Mhm.
Das ist ein Ding, ne? Wollte ja nur mal gucken, ob du das äh Datum aus dem Kopf hast.
Nee, hatte ich nicht, äh, im, im, im Kopf, allerdings, äh, ist es bei mir halt sehr viel mehr dann mit dem äh,
elften September zweitausendeins verbunden, weil dann äh am zwölften September war ja dann zwanzig Jahre
Jahre CCC damals und es war eigentlich immer so bisschen Ziel und Erwartung mit V zusammen. Dieses Event zu begehen, damit wir irgendwie auch mal richtig erfahren, wie es eigentlich war in den ersten zwanzig Jahren. Und dann ist er einfach ganz frech äh so weggestorben und hat uns erstmal so etwas leer dagelassen
und in gewisser Hinsicht war das dann aber auch so der Ansporn, es nochmal richtig krachen zu lassen und
das ist ja dann auch total durch die Decke gegangen mit Blinken Lights und äh unserer Zwanzig-Jahres-CCC-Party, die ja auch relativ äh fett war, die dann aber wiederum,
nochmal überschattet wurde natürlich von diesem Terroranschlägen in den USA und das äh wurde dann wirklich zu einer der verrücktesten Wochen meines Lebens
das werde ich äh nicht vergessen.
Hoffen wir, dass wir dieses Jahr äh irgendwie eine bessere Zeit haben mit vierzig Jahre CCC.
Ja, wir halten auf jeden Fall noch so lange durch bis zur Party, oder?
Ja, da wollen wir mal drauf hoffen.
Ist der böse Corona nicht schnappt vorher.
In den Shownotes, die ähm die Filmseite, alles ist eins außer der Null. Äh neunundzwanzigster siebter ist das äh,
Datum des Film-Lounges. Ihr könnt euch jetzt schon mal rausschauen, in welches geile Open Air Kino ihr vielleicht dann gehen könnt, um diesen Film zu schauen und ob es nicht in eurem lokalen Chaos auch deine
Ein Begleitprogramm gibt, ähm,
wie gesagt, da gibt's keine Form, in die das gepresst wird. Das ist einfach dann eine Initiative der lokalen Gruppen, die das machen, was sie können und worauf sie Lust haben. Vielleicht gehört ihr ja selber zu so einer Gruppe, habt da Bock was zu machen.
Oder seid an der lokalen Gruppe interessiert, dann könnt ihr da mal fragen vielleicht wann die mit euch den Film gucken gehen oder ob sie irgendwas vorhaben, wie auch immer, ja? Äh,
kann ich ähm empfehlen.
Genau.
Und dann gab's noch was äh mit offenen Briefen und äh neuen Allianzen. Was ist denn da los?
Ja.
Viele Leute haben's auch äh genau erkannt, äh die die Hölle ist zugefroren,
Es gibt einen ähm offenen Brief, der sich an die Bundesregierung und die mit dem Staatstrianer-Thematiken befassten,
Ausschüsse des Bundestag gerichtet hat und da geht es genau um das Thema mit über das ich ja hier mit Andre auch kürzlich so ein kleines äh Logbuch Netzpolitik Spezial hatte, nämlich,
die Staatstrojaner Ausweitungsgesetze, die jetzt zum Ende der Legislaturperiode,
nochmal äh kommen sollen und zwar das Gesetz zur Anpassung des Verfassungsschutzrechts, dass eben,
allen deutschen Geheimdiensten die Befugnis zum Hacken geben soll und dem Bundespolizeigesetz.
Dass der Bundespolizei das Recht geben soll, äh Leute zu hacken.
Die noch gar keine Straftat begangen haben oder einer Straftat verdächtigt werden. Und mit dieser.
Ausweitung einhergehen soll ja ähm die Pflicht kommen, dass Anbieter von Internetdiensten.
Aktiv bei der Infektion der Geräte ihrer Kundinnen mitwirken müssen,
Ähm und das ist ja, also wir haben's in der Sendung äh besprochen, wenn ihr die Sendung mit Andre noch nicht gehört habt, kann ich die enorm empfehlen. Die war wirklich sehr gut, weil Andre dieses Thema wirklich wie kein anderer,
durchdrungen hat, das ist die LNP drei neun fünf gute Geheimdienstegesetz und ich sag muss ja wirklich sagen, mit Staatswehren setze ich mich ja auch auseinander, ne, so ist das ja nicht. Ich habe ja auch ähm.
Ein oder zwei Stellungen nahmen zu dem Thema an äh an den Deutschen Bundestag geschrieben. Aber der Andre.
Ist da einfach noch viel fitter in dem Ding, als äh ich das bin und ich glaube, er ist wahrscheinlich auch der Fitteste in dem Thema, den man überhaupt finden kann.
Deswegen die LMP drei neun fünf nochmal empfohlen, um damit.
Worum es da geht und wogegen wir uns da aussprechen. So, das Spannende an diesem Sachverhalt war jetzt, weil ja die Anbieterinnen verpflichtet werden sollen, ihre eigenen Kundinnen zu hacken im Auftrag der Geheimdienste
Ähm haben selbst Facebook und Google gesagt, äh da geht uns jetzt irgendwie ein bisschen zu weit, ja? Und es gibt einen,
einen offenen Brief ähm zu den Unterzeichnerinnen gehören äh.
Eco Verband der Internetwirtschaft, ne? Wir wissen, Klaus Landefeld, äh der ja auch bei uns schon zu Gast war. Der Bundesverband IT-Mittelstand, ähm die Stiftung Neue Verantwortung, beziehungsweise hier steht, es wäre nur Sven Herpig, ich weiß nicht genau, warum da nur sein Name steht, wird seine Gründe haben. Mailbox dot org, ähm
äh der JP Berlin, der politische Provider, der Verband, der Anbieter von Telekommunikations und,
Telekommunikations- und Mehrwertdiensten der VATM, Mail DE
Bundesverband IT-Sicherheit äh so Boxcript, so ein äh Cloud-Verschlüsselungsdienst. Jetzt kommen die äh unterhaltsam, ne, Tutanotha haben wir ja hier auch öfter behandelt, ne? Ebenfalls ein E-Mail
Provider, der sich gegen die äh Überwachungsanordnungen, gegen seine.
Nutzerinnen wert. Und jetzt kommt die äh die, sage ich mal, der Teil der Unterzeichnerin, die äh die Aufmerksamkeit, glaube ich, äh geholt haben, mega,
Chaos, Computerklub
Google und Facebook. So und äh das hat würde ich sagen, seine Wirkung nicht verfehlt. Mein Lieblings,
Tweet äh zu dem Thema kam von hier Isotop äh Informatiker ähm,
der schrieb, du weißt, dass du als Regierung komplett unrettbar verkackt hast, wenn ein Statement Sätze wie diesen enthält. Der CCC wendet sich in dem gemeinsamen, offenen Brief zusammen mit Facebook, Komma Google.
Der CCC zusammen mit Facebook und Google.
Der CCC. Und ja, die haben alle recht. Ja, habe ich mich sehr drüber gefreut. Natürlich ist das ähm.
Auch nicht ohne Kritik geblieben, dass der Chaos-Computer-Club die gleiche Meinung wie Facebook und Google hat, wenn es darum geht, ob Facebook und Google ihre eigenen Nutzerinnen hacken sollen. Ähm.
Ja, diese Perspektive ist sicherlich auch wertvoll. Ähm ich denke, wichtig ist an dieser Stelle die Aufmerksamkeit für dieses Thema zu generieren.
Und das ist äh sehr eindeutig gelungen. Und ähm das Thema war sehr unterbelichtet und ich hoffe, hoffe, hoffe, hoffe, die Legislaturperiode ist ja bald vorbei. Es gibt irgendwie nur noch,
anderthalb quasi Sitzungswochen und ähm bis dahin muss das Ding entweder,
Also muss das Ding vom Tisch sein, damit es beerdigt wird. Und deswegen brauchen wir jetzt alle Aufmerksamkeit und allen Druck auf diesem Thema.
Und ich habe auch äh auf Frage von Netzpolitik Org auch geantwortet, weißt du, wenn wenn ein eine Idee so gefährlich ist.
Dass alle davor waren. Andre hat ja auch in der letzten Sendung schon gesagt, Kurt Graulich hat davor gewarnt.
Facebook, Google, niemand sagt, dass es eine gute Idee, dann frage ich mich, äh warum man das verheimlichen sollte und sagt, nee, ähm wir sind ähm,
Wir sind zwar dagegen, aber wenn Facebook und Google dagegen sind, dann dann äh sind wir nicht dagegen oder was? Oder dann beteiligen wir uns nicht an dem
an dem Protest, ja? Und wenn es einfach mal darum geht zu zeigen, so die Idee ist so scheiße, dass selbst Facebook
Google und CC gemeinsam an einem Strang ziehen, das kriegst du halt selten und äh entsprechend habe ich mich auch sehr,
über das Echo gefreut. Auch von denjenigen, die dann meinen, wir hätten das nicht machen sollen, das fand ich äh auch sehr äh reizvoll dieses.
Ja gut, ich meine Facebook und Google ist ja klar, ne, warum die dagegen sind, ne, weil die sich natürlich nicht äh instrumentalisieren lassen wollen und äh dadurch natürlich vor allem befürchten, massiv bei ihren
äh Kunden zu verkacken, absolut nachvollziehbar und das ist ja auch so ein Grundproblem dabei, wie äh alle Entschlüsselungsdebatten auch,
und das ist äh glaube ich auch so ein Fight, den die Politik äh äh demnächst noch härter führen wird mit der äh Wirtschaft, weil die halt einfach keinen Bock haben, sich
sozusagen ihr Kundenverhältnis vollständig zerstören zu lassen.
Ja, absolut, also ne, dass äh natürlich ist das deren äh Motivation, ja, aber äh die also diese Motivation, man muss ja mal, also.
In dieser dreizehn Fragen Sendung gestern, ne, habe ich ja auch natürlich das Verbot
das Geschäftsmodell von Facebook gefordert und die Zerschlagung, ja. Es ist ja nicht so, als wäre ich ein Facebook-Freund. Äh Facebook Feind und äh nutze das nicht.
Und äh hoffe, dass wir das irgendwann überkommen in unserer Gesellschaft. Ähm.
Man darf sich aber auch echt nicht vergessen, das sind supernationale Konzerne, die also die sehr viel mehr.
Einfluss haben, als was weiß ich, die Bundesrepublik. Und ähm die sich auch gegen sehr viel mehr Einfluss überall auf dieser Welt wehren müssen.
Ähm wo nämlich Staaten versuchen, diesen Laden und irgendwie unter ihre Kontrolle zu bringen,
So und da bist du in Ländern wie Deutschland noch relativ gut aufgehoben, wenn du nämlich mal schaust, was irgendwie in anderen Staaten so los ist. Und diese, also während Google und Facebook,
hier äh zurecht sehr stark äh kritisiert werden.
Sind sie in anderen Ländern tatsächlich noch sehr viel stärker ähm ja, wie soll man das sagen.
Dabei Meinungsfreiheit gegen staatliche Eingriffe zu stärken. Ja, das sind aber eben auch andere Staaten, äh die auch im weitesten Sinne nicht demokratisch sind. Ich will jetzt gar nicht deren Rolle dort loben, ich will nur sagen,
die ganze Zeit irgendwie ich weiß nicht, wie viele Staaten gibt's? Hundertsechzig oder so? Hundertsechzig.
Zweihundert.
Okay, ich wollte da jetzt keinen Start vergessen, alle Staaten sind schön. Ähm diese ganzen Staaten kläffen denen die ganze Zeit ans Bein und wollen sich derer bemächtigen und die sind natürlich,
befasst sich dagegen zu wehren. Und wenn sie in Deutschland die Auflage bekommen.
Mal bitte eure Nutzer, dann kommt selbstverständlich als nächstes Schiener und sagt übrigens, ihr habt da was Schönes gebaut. Das könnt ihr bei uns auch mal direkt ausrollen, ne? Und,
insofern natürlich ist jegliche ähm.
Motivation, bei denen am Ende, also jedes Mal, wenn sie im Interesse ihrer Nutzerinnen für irgendwas kämpfen, ist das, weil sie diese Nutzerinnen behalten wollen, weil sie weiter monetarisieren wollen. Das ändert aber nichts daran, dass sie hier an dieser Stelle für eine wichtige,
ähm Sache kämpfen, die ja nicht nur sie betrifft, sondern auch hier eben so kleinere Unternehmen wie unter den Unterzeichnenden Mail DE, Mailbox dot org oder Tutanota.
So und wer ja auch lustig, wenn die jetzt ohne die Macht von Facebook und Google dagegen kämpfen sollen,
Ja, also das ist äh ich denke, das Argument, äh ihr seid einer Meinung, aber ihr dürft nicht gemeinsam äh diese Meinung vertreten, trägt dann nicht weit. Genauso wenig wie das Argument, äh dass äh der Chaos Computerclub jetzt ähm.
Facebook segnen würde oder dass Facebook jetzt in der mehr Nutzerin kriegt, weil weil alle sich denken, oh krass, boah Facebook, alles klar, dann kann ja doch auf Facebook gehen.
Genau, bevor äh die passenden Kommentare dazukommen, korrigiere ich's gleich mal nach, also offiziell gibt es hundertdreiundneunzig,
die äh unumstritten sind und damit Mitglieder der Vereinten Nationen. Außerdem gibt's aber dann noch äh ungefähr äh dann gibt's noch sowas wie Vatikan statt und irgendwie zwölf andere Staaten, die sagen wir mal, äh,
Zumindest von anderen Ländern äh eingeschränkt anerkannt werden,
oder sich in freier Assoziierung zu anderen Staaten befinden. Sowas soll's ja auch geben.
Welche sind äh welche sind das?
Die in freier Asoziierung sind na ja ich würde so sagen ist wahrscheinlich sowas wie Transnistrien und so die,
Südostsees hier in wo Russland sozusagen anerkennt, aber andere Staaten nicht und dann diese Taiwan, China-Situation, all so eine Sachen Macau. Also
da ähm ist auf jeden Fall zweihundert ist jetzt nicht,
nicht schlecht geraten gewesen von mir, obwohl ich ehrlich gesagt wenigstens hätte hinschreiben sollen, wahrscheinlich zweihundertdreißig gesagt hätte, aber egal. Also wir haben ungefähr zweihundert Staaten äh auf dieser.
Erde und das reicht ja dann auch.
Hoffen wir mal, dass dass wir da jetzt nicht in irgendeinen Wespennest getreten sind. Sehen wir bestimmt.
Bestimmt, bestimmt.
Okay.
Ja, also das ist und entscheidend ist hier die Aufmerksamkeit auf das Thema und die haben wir glaube ich relativ erfolgreich generiert und hoffen jetzt, dass es natürlich auch bei den.
Verantwortlichen, Politikerinnen ein Prozess des Umdenkens anregt, wenn sie sich mal denken, äh okay krass, da sind jetzt irgendwie so wirklich alle dagegen.
Ähm vom Eco über die
kleine, zarte Pflanze der mittelständischen Wirtschaft, die wir hier noch nicht kaputtgetreten haben, über die NGOs, über oder über einige NGOs und über äh die großen Konzerne. Vielleicht sollten wir uns überlegen, ob wir da gerade,
äh wirklich etwas machen, das niemand möchte. Ja.
Gut, schauen wir mal, ähm nach Dänemark. Sag mal, Linus, erinnerst du dich noch? Wie war das eigentlich mit dem Ausspähen unter Freunden?
Das geht gar nicht.
Geht gar nicht, oder?
Nee. Ja, kannst du nicht machen.
Das ist einfach, das ist nicht okay und ähm aber das Überraschende ist, findet statt. Hatten,
und äh das war wer das äh Zitat jetzt so nicht mehr erinnert, das war ja so das Statement von äh Angela Merkel, nachdem die ganzen Snowden Enthüllung aufgekommen sind und sich in Deutschland der NSA Untersuchungsausschuss,
herausbildete und all diese ganzen Wehen und was haben wir gesehen? Überall wurde irgendwie überwacht, überall wurde,
kooperiert mit der NSA, der äh BND war ganz fleißig dabei, dem NSA,
Zugriff zu geben zur deutschen Infrastruktur
Ja, da waren dann Überwachungsstationen, wo dann die Amerikaner fleißig selektoren eingespeist haben, so nach dem Motto hier, das sind hier sind unsere Suchrequests, hier sind unsere Suchstrinks
Inklusion, unsere Exklusion und gibt uns doch mal ein bisschen was ab von dem, was ihr da irgendwie aus dem Äther kratzt oder aus euren Datenleitungen saugt, was da in
äh ja beim beim Dezix in den Knoten hin und her fliegt. All das haben wir hier, eine Milliarde mal besprochen.
Und stellt sich raus ähnliche Dinge passieren auch in Dänemark und da gab es schon vor einiger Zeit ein Geheimdienstskandal, der tatsächlich von den ganzen NSA Enthüllungen
ausgelöst wurde, weil es gab dann nämlich tatsächlich eine interne
Untersuchung der Geheimdienstaktivitäten in Dänemark, weil man sich gedacht hat, na ja so, also wenn das da so in Deutschland so läuft, so.
Gucken wir auch mal lieber, ob bei uns dann irgendwie auch noch was äh falsch läuft und
gibt dann tatsächlich auch eine passende Aufsichtsbehörde. Ähm immerhin gibt's sowas, eine Überwachung der Nachrichtendienste, TET, wie ich versuche das jetzt mal nicht auf dänisch auszusprechen, weil ich habe keine Ahnung von dänisch
und ich freue mich gerade, so etwas wie eine Aufsichtsbehörde, über.
Geheimdienste, den Level hat es ja in Deutschland noch nicht mal, ne. Wir haben eigentlich ja nur so diesen parlamentarischen äh.
Das hätte ich fast wieder PKK gesagt, wie heißt das jetzt?
PKGR.
Kommission hat sich ja umbenennt, genau, hat sich ja jetzt umbenannt, genau. Und ähm das war's dann eigentlich. Den darf ab und zu mal ein bisschen was erzählt werden, aber die dürfen's auch keinem weiter erzählen, aber dass wir das so wirklich so auf dem Level einer Behörde haben, das äh wäre mir jetzt neu.
Also dazu geben. Was die Sache nicht unbedingt transparenter macht, weil das Ganze ist dann zwanzig fünfzehn schon angeleiert worden und tatsächlich gab es wohl auch Ergebnisse, die wurden aber dann nicht weitergereicht.
So, weil na ja, also wenn das jetzt auch noch einer erfahren würde,
Wäre ja nicht so gut, weil stellt sich dann raus und es wurde dann eben von neun Monaten über Whistleblower an die Presse gelegt.
Dass sehr wohl äh eine ähnliche Praxis in Dänemark auch stattgefunden hat.
Da betrifft das Ganze betrifft ähm quasi so das BND Äquivalent in äh Dänemark, der militärische Geheimdienst, abgekürzt
FE, auch hier verzichte ich jetzt mal auf dänische Aussprache, auch wenn sich diese Worte so interessant lesen,
Heißt aber letzten Endes auch nicht sehr viel anderes. Und als es dann eben in die Presse ging, dann ist es irgendwie ordentlich, hat's ordentlich geklackert und äh unter anderem musste dann erstmal der Chef äh zu,
und am Ende ist eigentlich auch die komplette gesamte Führung von diesem FE äh gegangen worden.
Ja, insofern alles wunderbar.
Also auch dort ähm sind halt Abholstationen von Dänemark mitgenutzt worden über solche Selektoren und ähm wenig überraschend wurde unter anderem auch Angela Merkel und Frank-Walter Steinmeier
damals äh Außenminister in Deutschland äh überwacht. Das war wohl auch schon bekannt.
Habe ich jetzt diesen Berichten entnommen. Mir war's ehrlich gesagt noch nicht bekannt, dass es irgendwie nicht so richtig durchgedrungen und die eigentliche, wirkliche Neuigkeit ist wohl, dass auch per Steinbrück davon
betroffen war, der damals ja Finanzminister war
Außerdem lagen wohl noch diverse andere Politiker in diesen Selektoren aus Schweden, Norwegen und äh Frankreich und jetzt regen sich natürlich alle auf jetzt, wo das irgendwie in der Presse ist,
da. Per Steinbrück meinte dazu, er sei aber nicht sauer.
Nur enttäuscht.
Hätte nur äh äh Spott Spott. Ja, er würde es grotesk finden, was dort abgelaufen ist.
Okay. Protest.
Grotesk.
Ja, mehr als Sport äh gibt's nicht. Weiß ich nicht ganz genau, wen er da jetzt verspotten äh möchte, also die Dänen oder so, das weiß ich nicht so ganz genau.
Eigentlich heißt es ja immer, den Lügen nicht, aber da scheint wohl auch nicht so viel dran zu sein.
Ich habe nur Spott. Okay.
Finde das Statement, ehrlich gesagt, ein bisschen grotesk.
Das ist wirklich getestet, siehst du? Ah, die haben mich ausspioniert. Das ist so gut teste. Das ist ja Spott, Alter. Ich habe doch gar nichts zu verbergen. Also.
Ich erzähle eh nur so belangloses Zeug.
Vergeudet, hätte wenigstens einen Mittelfinger zeigen können.
Ja, da ist Deutschland doch total äh super drin, ne? Hast du gesehen, Eurovision Song Contest? Da hat's Deutschland mal richtig einen gezeigt.
Und den Mittelfinger so breit ausgeklappt. Hast du wahrscheinlich gar nicht mitbekommen, ne?
Dich, dass er dich. Ich habe das äh tatsächlich äh kurz mit ansehen müssen und es war wirklich äh furchtbar. In der Hüfte wirklich so ein so ein so ein so ein Rolf auf der Bühne mit rum.
Ernsthaft, also so eine Person in so einem in so einem Rollkostüm, so mit fünf Fingern,
die ganze Zeit um diesen äh äh Sänger mit seinem lächerlichen Song irgendwie, dass ich angeblich gegen Hass im Netz richten sollte.
Hüpfte die ganze Zeit irgendwie diese Figur rum und war eigentlich die ganze Zeit so mitm Fuckfinger nach oben und äh,
bin mir nicht so sicher, was was sie damit bezwecken wollten und ob sie sozusagen so dem Hass im Netz den Fuck Finger entgegen zeigen wollten. Ich habe einfach nur gesehen, Deutschland hüpft irgendwie mit fünf
mit mit Rolf und fünf irgendwie auf der Bühne rum und sagt einfach, fuck
Da gab's dann auch drei Punkte für am Ende irgendwie. Von ein paar hundert, paar hundert.
Fußballpunkte.
Nee, Vorletzter, nee, Vorletzter Platz und nur erkannt war so schlecht, dass es noch nicht mal für den letzten Platz gereicht hat. An der Stelle auch wieder total enttäuscht.
Deutschland und der ESC ist ja auch äh ja eine Geschichte voller äh Höhepunkte.
Ja, Missverständnisse. Ja, aber der Rolf äh Rolf kommt wieder, ja, also Rolf Forever.
Na ja, okay, fünf.
Fünf.
Dann haben wir noch.
Amazon hat auch eine geile Idee. Ähm.
Und äh stellt auch seine Nutzer jetzt fristgerecht eine Woche vorher, vor die vor die einfache Wahl da vielleicht nicht mitzuspielen,
Und zwar hat ja Amazon zu diverses Gerät am Markt. Äh manches haben sie selber entwickelt, wie diese ganzen Echo Devices mit ihrem Alexa drauf,
Das ist ja auch relativ erfolgreich. Und dann haben sie auch noch die ein oder andere
Akquisition im IoT-Bereich gemacht, ähm meisten kennt man, glaube ich, diese Ring-Devices, die so Kameras, Türklingeln und so weiter sind, die auch schon ihren Share an Sicherheitslücken äh hatten.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz weit verbreitet sind und
ja dazu führen, dass irgendwie überall alles rausliegt. Äh da ist ja niemand so richtig vor verschont auch jetzt hier gerade auch im äh
Homekit, Apple, äh Universum gab's ja auch so einen relativ populären Kameraüberwacher, der irgendwie so seine Security-Kredenz ein bisschen durcheinander bekommen hat und haben die Leute einfach.
Nicht die Bilder von ihrer eigenen Sicherheitskamera bekommen, sondern von irgendwelchen anderen. So, auch super. Einfach mal andere Gesichter sehen, so.
Warum nicht mal eine andere Perspektive, ja? Immer gleiche Ecke hängen.
Haben wir alle gesagt bekommen, wenn wir das mal einfach auch mal einen anderen Blickwinkel einnehmen muss. Ja. Äh und wenn's dann mal so ist, schweren sich gleich wieder alle dadrüber. Ja.
Das sind die Scheuklappen, Tim. Das sind die Scheuklappen. Immer nur, weißt du, das sind die Nimbis, ne. Die denen geht's dann aufn Sack, wenn sie mal einen anderen äh Vorgarten schauen müssen, ja, das ist äh.
Na ja, auf jeden Fall war's das zeigt, ist diese ganze IOT,
Sache, diese kleinen, intelligenten, die weiß ist, ja, die ja nicht nur schon uns die ganze Zeit zuhören und versuchen, sich da einen Reim drauf zu machen,
Manche nehmen sie das alles ohnehin zentral prozessieren, wie es halt bei Amazon üblich ist und äh andere so wie Apple das macht, die zumindest versuchen, irgendwie den Kram noch so in den eigenen vier Wänden zu verstehen, mit ein bisschen Hilfe aus dem Netz
sind natürlich vor allem auch so aktive,
Teilnehmer des eigenen Netzwerks und da man natürlich auf diese Software keinen Zugriff hat und die sich ja auch permanent aktualisieren können.
Liegt es dann doch schon sehr in der Hand des Herstellers? Wie sehr einen das jetzt irgendwie gefährdet oder nicht. Also wenn's wenn's morgen bei Alexa eine eine generelle Sicherheitslücke äh gibt, die du vielleicht eine Woche lang nicht gefixt wird.
Ja, dann sind halt einfach Millionen von Haushalten unmittelbar sofort davon betroffen.
Und das sollte man immer im Kopf haben. Und äh jetzt hat Amazon äh etwas angekündigt mit dem schönen Namen Sidewalk.
So der digitale Bürgersteig, den sie da äh aufbauen wollen, wobei sie da eigentlich auch sich erstmal selbst im Sinn haben. Die Idee ist, dass sie mit all ihren Internetconnected Devices, die bei den Kunden rumstehen
das jeweilige Netzwerk an dem sie angeschlossen sind auch.
Anderen Geräten aus ihrer Familie bereitstellen, selbst wenn die eben nicht,
ins selbe Netzwerk gehören. Also sagen wir mal, du wohnst irgendwo und dann äh hat die Person über dir
und dann sehen die sich natürlich über das WLAN und ähm die Vorstellung von Amazon ist, dass sie dann quasi so einen zweiten Kanal aufmachen und sagen
liebes Nachbargerät falls dein Internet ausfällt, kein Problem, hier oben läuft's ja vielleicht noch, kannst du dann einfach
über mich laufen lassen. Wobei sich das jetzt eben nur auf so sagen wir mal Normaltreffic
bezieht, da geht's jetzt nicht dadrum, gleich Videoströme durch die Gegend zu leiten, aber zumindest diese und sie versprechen sich halt äh einerseits eine gewisse Ausfallsicherheit
sie damit sicherlich auch ähm generieren könnten und natürlich auch Hilfe beim Setup
weil es ja immer so ein bisschen tricky ist, solche Geräte äh überhaupt erstmal aufsetzen zu können, bevor sie Netz haben und wofür sie dann aber meistens irgendwie Netz brauchen und dann gib hier ein und so weiter. Und ich glaube, ihre Vorstellung ist so ein bisschen, du hältst halt irgendwo so einen Alexa äh Würfel hin, der sieht so, ah ja, guck mal hier, beim Nachbarn gibt's ja mal kurz Netz.
Lass mich mal kurz hier äh zum Zwecke des Setups ein paar Daten austauschen, dann dann geht es irgendwie einfacher.
Also es gibt ja schon immer wieder Ideen.
Die Internetanschlüsse, die die Leute haben, in irgendeiner Weise, ja, zu scheren, so.
Pfoten war die erste Idee.
Genau. Vorhin waren die ersten. Die haben gesagt, wir wir haben einen äh WiFi Access-Point, den haust du bei dir rein. Der macht ein Wifi für dich und einen offenes für Leute, die auch so ein Fon.
Die die keinen haben, können Geld bezahlen.
Und dann haben die im Zweifelsfall, na, also es war im Prinzip die Idee frei Funk auf eine ja im weitesten Sinne kommerzielle,
zu setzen. Und die Idee war gar nicht so enorm unsympathisch, weil es halt dieses, ne, gibt's jetzt du teilst zu Hause, dann kriegst du woanders. Ähm ich habe in,
Frankreich glaube ich, hat SFR das auch gemacht. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob die das immer noch machen. Die haben im Prinzip auch gesagt, pass auf, unser.
Du wir haben, wir stellen dir einen Router hin.
Dirk, du kannst das an- und ausmachen und je nachdem, ob du es an, ob du es an und aus machst, kannst du es auch woanders verwenden, ne? Denn haben einfach alle Router, die das angeschaltet haben und irgendwo rumstanden haben, eben auch ihr WLAN geteilt. Und
das kann natürlich potentiell totale ähm Vorteile haben. Ähm,
für dich selber auch, ne? Weil du äh,
vielleicht ja nicht so viel Bandbreite zu Hause teilst und diese Dinger immer noch deine private Bandbreite gegenüber der geteilten priorisieren und so und du dafür irgendwo anders Fehlern hast, die ich fand diese Grundidee immer gar nicht
so verkehrt. Ähm.
Man fragt sich aber natürlich, na ja, bei diesem Fondingern und so, spalt ja den anderen Kram denn jetzt auch wirklich durch irgendein anderes VPN, damit das nicht, wenn da irgendjemand Mist macht mit meiner IP im Internet steht und so.
Ein anderer bei, ein anderes Beispiel ist dieses Feind-Main-Netzwerk, was Apple jetzt macht, das ist ja auch eigentlich ein Mesh Network, was Sie aufbauen, aber wenn irgend so ein Airtag nach Hause funkt, dann tut es das durch dein iPhone auf deine Kosten,
ne? Und also.
Ein verlorenes Attack, an dem du vorbeiläufst, das sich irgendwie mit deinem iPhone oder mittelst, deinem iPhone sagt übrigens, ich bin hier und dann sagt dein iPhone, Apple Bescheid. Das ist etwas, was dein iPhone tut.
Auf deine, ja, paar Daten kosten. Ähm das eventuell nicht in deinem Interesse ist.
Ja, das kann man natürlich argumentieren, wobei
der Aufwand nur wirklich so dermaßen minimal ist, dass dass das, glaube ich, die Diskussion gar nicht so richtig äh äh wert ist, insbesondere, wenn man sich anschaut, wie sich Datentarife generell so
äh verhalten, ne. Schon auch ist schon ein bisschen was anderes, aber das steckt natürlich hier auch mit drin. Weil dieses Sidewalk,
potentiell natürlich auch versucht, für Amazon so eine,
Deckung der Gegend zu sicherzustellen. Also angenommen Amazon wollte jetzt auch so etwas wie diese Airtex rausgeben. Muss ja so durchaus,
in ihre DNA passen würde. Ja, solche, solche Tracker äh äh Dinger. Grade im Hinblick auf Paket äh Lieferung und so, also.
Könnte könnte in jeder Hinsicht ganz interessant sein. Und da wollen die natürlich auch mit relativ geringen technischen Aufwand,
diese Dinger finden, ne? Diese ATEX, die haben ja außer Bluetooth und diesen neuen,
Frequenzen und NFC ist da ja nicht
drin, die WLAN, die haben ja keinen GPS-Empfänger oder sowas. Die müssen von anderen gesehen und berichtet werden, damit das irgendwie funktioniert. Und Amazon hat halt kein vergleichbares Netzwerk, weil sie eben keine Mobilfunkplattform aufgebaut,
bekommen, ne? Haben's ja mal probiert, eigene Telefone zu machen, das ist komplett in die Hose gegangen und da haben sie, glaube ich, auch nicht mehr viel zu melden,
nur Google und Apple haben überhaupt derzeit die Möglichkeit, solche Tracking-Netzwerke aufzubauen.
Deswegen wollen die auf ihr wollen die jetzt ihre Geräte nehmen.
Das jetzt so der Hauptgrund ist oder nur so ein Nebeneffekt, je nachdem wie gut's dann läuft, weiß man nicht, aber ist auf jeden Fall erstmal besser äh das zu haben als nicht zu haben.
Und äh ja. Wie sieht das jetzt eigentlich aus? Also sie haben es angekündigt, dass sie das einfach mal einschalten.
Ahnt, wenn man das nicht möchte, dann gibt's irgendwie einen Opt-Out und das äh binnen einer Woche. Die Meldung ist jetzt von vom ersten Juni, also
am achten Juni wäre dann sozusagen der Stichtag und dann werden alle äh Amazon Devices quasi in sogenanntes Sidewalk Bridges,
umgebaut, ne? Gut, ich glaube Ihnen jetzt mal, dass dann der Zugriff schon ähm ich sage jetzt mal nicht verschlüsselt, aber zumindest so kanalisiert ist, dass dass man eben keinen Zugriff auf das Heimnetz bekommt und ähm
Austauschen von so ein bisschen Metadaten ist sicherlich jetzt auch nicht,
Datentarif äh relevant ist, eher eine grundsätzliche Frage, wie ähm man so was findet.
Ja, es ist.
Also ich finde, es ist halt das das wie sie es machen ist natürlich wieder total daneben, ne? Wir wir schieben das rein und du musst,
sagen, du willst es nicht, äh wenn und hm.
Das ist schön. Und vor allem, wenn sie's, sie wollen's ja offenbar auch mit ihren Eco Devices machen, ne? Und von denen steht natürlich schon eine ganze Menge rum, weil das sind doch diese diese äh Smart Speaker oder nicht?
Alexa Teile, genau.
Ja, also ich.
Und vor allem, was ich daran halt so erstaunlich finde oder was da natürlich auffällig ist, sie machen's ja nur für zu ihrem eigenen ähm.
Für ihr eigenes Interesse, ne? Unsere Geräte funktionieren gemashed mit unseren Geräten und wir nennen das.
Sidewalk, ich, also ich würd's wahrscheinlich auch ausschalten, wenn ich 'n Amazon-Gerät hätte.
Ja, aber die Situation bisher gar nicht erst gekommen.
In die Situation bin ich nicht gekommen. Wir müssen wichtig noch dazu sagen, das ist jetzt nur in den USA, ne? Also in.
Deutschland ist das nicht der Fall. Also ihr müsst jetzt nicht diesen, ihr könnt euch nur darauf auf, ihr könnt euch darauf vorbereiten, dass dieses Thema früher oder später bei euch aufkommt.
Und ähm ihr müsst aber jetzt nicht bei Amazon äh anrufen, euren äh irgendwo widersprechen oder irgendein Häkchen wegmachen.
Es sei denn, euer Gerät ist irgendwie magisch als ich stehe in den USA geteckt, aber ja, keine Ahnung. Wovon das äh abhängt. Also wie sie das erkennen, dass ein Gerät in USA ist? Wahrscheinlich eine IP-Adresse und so.
Ja, das wahrscheinlich einfach daran, in welchem Amazon-Account der äh angebunden ist, oder?
Oder oder das. Also es kann halt auch amerikanische Accounts sein, also was jetzt US Customers genau heißt, ist halt die Frage, ne, wird das äh geographisch äh ermittelt.
Fällt man da schon rein, wenn man irgendwie ein VPN noch an seinem Netz hat, was in den USA rauskommt oder hängt es eben davon ab, wo dieser Account registriert ist? Keine Ahnung.
Aber es ist spannend und ich erinnere mich, dass wir da nach der letzten Apple Keynote auch mit Sascha Lobo ja ein bisschen drüber gequatscht hatten in auf Clubhaus. Ähm dass diese Unternehmen jetzt so ihre eigenen.
Netzwerke so bauen, ne,
Also Apple mit Feind, Mei, außen nichts heraus sagen, wir haben so und so viele Dinger da draußen, die sind jetzt unsere Sensoren fürn weltumspannendes äh Tracking, ein Netzwerk für Kleinstgeräte. Hm und,
die.
Google und Apple ja auch schon seit, das ist ja schon sehr lange her, dass äh interessiert ja heute schon gar keinen mehr, dass die ja die Lokalisierungsdienste so gut gemacht haben, indem sie inzwischen die Telefone, die ähm
orten sich ja nur noch notfalls über GPS.
Sondern orten sich in der Regel darüber, welche WLANs sie gerade hören, ne? Und dass sie diese ganzen Geräte, die sie ja draußen haben im im Feld,
immer auch oder immer mehr auch als Sensoren.
Für sich selber ausgebaut haben. Und jetzt sogar zu, ja, Meternetzwerken. Das ist schon.
Oha, ich will nicht wissen, was die äh äh auf der Fünf- und Zehnjahres Roadmap stehen haben, ne. Das ist dann schon spannend.
Also es wird eh noch also spannend ist das richtige Wort. Ich meine, stell dir mal vor, was man damit, also man,
ich will's jetzt auch gar nicht mal so verteufeln, ja, es kann auch eine ganze Menge interessantes, nützliches Zeug dabei rausfallen.
Also allein die Tatsache, dass jetzt wirklich Milliarden an Smartphones durch die Gegend getragen werden, die, wenn man sie zu einem Sensor-Netzwerk zusammenschaltet.
Ja? Im Prinzip ja auch Erdbeben messen können.
Also wenn du wenn du wirklich über die Daten aller Telefone rüber gehst und dann die äh Erschütterungssensoren auswertest
mit Sicherheit kannst du solche Erdbebensituationen feststellen und vielleicht sogar auch schon,
als Vorwarnungsding, ne? Dasselbe natürlich auch mit Mikrofonen oder äh,
Feuchtigkeitshöhensensensoren, keine Ahnung, also habe ich jetzt nicht wirklich bis zu Ende gedacht, aber ist einfach klar, dass wenn man.
All diese ganzen Sensoren äh sinnvoll auswertet und das ist ja äh zunehmende Maße möglich, dadurch dass die Hardware
diese ganzen Machine Learning, Hardwarebeschleunigung mit drin hat, das heißt, alles, worauf man mal trainiert hat, das lässt sich sehr äh batteriesparsam, einfach mal so parallel mit ähm abwickeln
Telefon zählt heute,
die Schritte, mit die man den Tag über macht, ja? Und Schritt ist jetzt nix, was irgendwie eindeutig von dem Körper signalisiert wird, sondern wie das so für so ein Telefon aussieht, hängt sehr davon ab, hältst das Ding in einer äh in der Tasche
hältst du das Ding in der Hand, hast du das Ding in der Tasche? Äh ja, wie bewegst du dich äh gerade
trotzdem sind die Geräte offensichtlich in der Lage, verhältnismäßig zuverlässig einen Schritt oder eben auch einen Laufen oder auch ein Fahrradfahren zu erkennen und das ist eben darüber möglich. Und das
bietet noch eine ganze Menge Potenzial. Es ist auf jeden Fall etwas, was man,
beobachten muss, inwiefern sich dann auch die Hersteller in Zukunft da Freiheiten herausnehmen, sich dieser Infrastruktur
in Form von ausgehändigten Geräten daherkommt, äh für sich nutzbar zu machen.
Ich äh verlinke in dem Kontext nochmal einen Artikel, einen Buchkapitel, was ich zwanzig fünfzehn geschrieben habe mit dem Titel Sensoren der Cloud in einem Buch mit dem Titel Internet der Dinge.
Und da äh habe ich gerade nochmal rausgesucht, müsst ihr nochmal lesen, wie wir gucken, wie gut der gealtert ist. Ich glaube, der es scheint mir noch ganz gut gealtert zu sein. Der endet mit äh frei nach Berthold Brecht. Was ist ein Einbruch in eine Bank gegen die Gründung einer Bank
daher die Frage, was ist ein Einbruch in ein Fitnessarmband gegen die Gründung einer Fitness-Cloud? Das äh.
Glaube ich, da habe ich so ein bisschen schon äh in diese Richtung auch geblickt. Artikel findet ihr oder Kapitel findet ihr in den Shownotes.
Fähigkeiten an Tag gelegt.
Habe ich versucht, habe ich versucht. Man muss sich ja, ne, so ein paar Dinger mal hinlegen und wenn man dann recht hatte, dann sagt man, habe ich damals schon gesagt und wenn nicht, sagst du äh.
Scrollt das halt weiter, ne? Aber bisher äh glaube ich, war das mit diesem schon auch sehr äh noch sehr vorhersehbar, was da die kommerziellen Interessen der Unternehmen sind.
Sind wir beim letzten Thema heute.
Netzpolitik Org verklagt die Zitis. Dicitis, boah man ey jedes Mal die Zentralstelle für.
Informationstechnik im Sicherheitsbereich ist ja die Hackerbehörde die Deutschland sich gegönnt hat.
Die für Geheimdienste und Strafverfolgungsbehörden ähm Kräfte in der Entschlüsselung.
Ähm und dem der IT-Sicherheit und der Schwächung von IT-Sicherheit bündeln soll. Und.
Rechtliche Grundlage dieser Behörde ist äh insofern.
Ungewöhnlich, weil es kein Gesetz gibt, was sagt, es gibt eine Zitis und das sind ihre Aufgaben. Also weder die Bundesregierung,
noch der Bundestag haben beschlossen,
dass es diese Behörde geben soll. Das ist bei den anderen Behörden in der Regel der Fall. Da steht, wir haben eine, was weiß ich, ein Bundeskriminalamt, das regelt das BKA-Gesetz und das BKA hat folgende Aufgaben, folgende nicht. Ähm.
Die Zitis wurde aber einfach per Ministerrialerlass ins Leben gerufen. Und zur Gründung, kurz darauf gab's dann eben ein, gab es ein Rechtsgutachten zur Aufgabenerfüllung.
Von dem Professor Doktor Heinrich Amadeus Wolf, der an der Universität Bayreuth einen Lehrstuhl innehat. Und die,
Netz für Tick Org hätten halt ganz gerne dieses Rechtsgutachten, in dem erklärt wird, was die für Aufgaben haben, wie sie die erfüllen sollen. Und,
Die Bundesregierung sagt einfach nur, dass Rechtsgutachten zur Aufgabenerfüllung der Zithes führt dazu aus, welche Rechtsnatür die Zites aufweist, welche konkreten Aufgaben der ministerielle
Errichtungserlass für die Zitis vorsieht. Wer die Zithes wie beauftragen kann.
Und wer nicht? Und wie sich die Fachaufsicht im Einzelnen darstellt, insbesondere in Ausprägung des Jahres Arbeitsprogramms. Also das steht da drin. Diese Informationen.
Hätte äh Netzkritik auch gerne gehabt, um diese neue Behörde, für die es ja gar keine Rechtsgrundlage gibt, mal äh.
Sich anzuschauen. Und dieses Gutachten, diesen Antrag, haben sie natürlich nach äh äh guter Manier über Frag den Staat äh angefragt. Und die Citis hat gesagt, das geben wir euch nicht. Denn.
Ähm.
Da steht ja auch was drin, weil über Geheimdienste und äh Geheimdienste fallen aber nicht unter das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz und deswegen fällt auch die Zites nicht unter das äh Informationsfreiheitsgesetz. Jetzt hat äh ähm,
gegen diese Ablehnung, Widerspruch eingelegt.
Weil die zieht es auf ihrer Webseite selber schreibt. Zitis ist weder eine polizeiliche noch eine nach indinstliche Stelle und hat folglich keine derartigen Befugnisse.
Ist immer schön, wenn du auf der ersten Seite schon den Widerspruch findest zur zur Kernthese.
Ähm und äh dann das Bundeskanzleramt arbeitet ja auch mit Geheimdiensten zusammen und fällt trotzdem unter das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz und,
außernehmen nimmt, die zieht es keine gesetzlich definierten Sicherheitsaufgaben wahr, äh sondern sie unterstützen und berät ja nur. Insofern sagen äh Netzpolitik Orgin fragt den Staat, natürlich fahrt ihr und das das Informations,
Freiheitsgesetz. Ähm ja, die Zitis hat diesen Widerspruch abgelehnt.
Ähm mit der gleichen Argumentation. Äh wir arbeiten mit Geheimdiensten, dass Rechtsgutachten analysiert diese zusammen Arbeit, also darf das Rechtsgutachten nicht bekannt werden. Äh und,
Außerdem
haben wir jetzt dieses Gutachten als Verschlusssache eingestuft. Das ist geil. Das Rechtsgutachten zu unserer Arbeitsgrundlage und unseren Aufgaben haben wir jetzt zur Verschlusssache gemacht. Ähm und deswegen.
Haben jetzt äh die Anwälte von Netzpolitik ORG mit frag den Staat,
Klage gegen die Zitis eingereicht, tschuldigung, die Anwältin, nicht die Anwälte. Anna äh Gilsbach von,
DKA Rechtsanwälte unterstützt, werden äh dabei von Frag den Staat, die das Verfahren bezahlen. Und das geht dann eben vor das Verwaltungsgericht,
München ist nicht die erste IFG-Klage, ganz im Gegenteil, das machen die ja regelmäßig und entsprechend hat ja den äh der juristische,
der juristische Arm zur Durchsetzung des Informationsfreiheitsgesetzes seit Längerem auch schon einfach ein eigenes Budget bei äh frag den Staat.
Ich find's echt äh bärenstark, was das, also was das für ein.
Also das zeigt halt diese Arbeit auf, ne,
Wir haben jetzt, wir erlassen hier mal eine neue Behörde, die äh als Bundesinnenministerium so, das soll jetzt mal hier stattfinden. Äh Thomas de Maizire war das übrigens noch, ne? Nicht, nicht Seehofer.
Und äh was die macht und auf welcher rechtlichen Grundlage und so, da machen wir schon mal eine ein machen wir ein Gutachten, aber das Gutachten halten wir unter Verschluss. Sind wir denn?
Wo sind wir denn hier?
Ich finde die für diese Überzwischenüberschrift hier in dem Artikel von der Politik. Schrödinger ist Geheimdienst. Ja, also irgendwie so ein bisschen, ja wir sind es, aber wir sind es auch irgendwie nicht.
Wir sind keiner. Es sei denn, du willst was von uns wissen, dann sind wir einer.
Genau.
Weiß nicht, ob wir einer sind, aber wenn du fragst, kommt's drauf an. Es ist äh ja und ich finde es nur.
Aber erst, wenn du fragst, wird es klar und deswegen ist es gut, dass man da jetzt reinbohrt, finde ich eine super Aktion.
Ne, das ist jetzt irgendwie wieder mal ein Beispiel von der soliden, politischen Arbeit,
Thema dranbleibt, dass man dann 'ne IFG-Anfrage stellt, ne?
Viele andere, inklusive würde ich sagen, mir und dir, haben Sie sich längst daran gewöhnt, es gibt diese CT jetzt, mal gucken, wann wir das nächste Mal von denen hören
ja? Aber irgendjemand muss ja auch dafür sorgen, dass man nochmal was von denen hört. Also Bohrt Andre da jetzt nach zusammen.
Ahne, beziehungsweise, ne, bei Andre das Team von, bei Arne das Team von frag den Start. Ähm die hier mit den Organisationen eben seit Jahren so eine krasse Arbeit leisten.
Und ähm bin ja nie müde ja, darauf zu achten, bei seinen Spenden, wie viel Ertrag die denn auch tatsächlich bringen.
Und äh gerade bei Netzpolitik Org und fragt den Staat, sieht man ja eine ganze Menge, was die machen mit einer ganz wenigen geringen Anzahl,
von Menschen und auch echt immer knappen Budgets. Da kann ich nur nochmal,
wiederholen, die brauchen jederzeit jede finanzielle Unterstützung, die sie brauchen können und die setzen das halt auch um in effiziente,
zielgerichtete wirksame journalistische und politische Arbeit vor den Gerichten.
Auch in den Details und auch in den, in den großen Themen. Ja, auch diese Sache mit den äh Staatstürianern hier in Bundespolizeigesetz und.
Verfassungsschutzgesetz Reform. Irgendjemand muss immer hingehen und diese ganzen Sachen recherchieren,
Irgendjemand muss immer hingehen und euch das erzählen und irgendjemand muss die Grundlage für den Widerstand gegen diese Dinge schaffen und ähm ja, in diesen Gruppen, also insbesondere bei Netzpolitik Org und bei.
Ähm fragt den Staat, also der Open Night Foundation, ist euer Geld da sehr gut aufgehoben.
Sehr effizient für wenig Geld, viel Output.
Gibt's auch umgekehrt.
Umgekehrt. Ich hoffe, dass wir da auch ganz gut abschneiden.
Wir wir ich würde sagen, wir haben auch für wenig Geld äh viel Output.
Genau.
Super. Damit haben wir's.
Ende der Sendung.
Ja, die Sonne scheint. Ich habe Hitzewellen, Scheißwetter, die Hitze.
Gehen runter.
Dann würde ich vorschlagen, machen wir einfach kurzen Prozess hier mit der Sendung. Das war's von uns für euch und ähm wir hören uns sicherlich bald wieder. Ich würde vorschlagen, die nächste Woche.
Und wir sind auch so ein bisschen auf dem Weg äh in sicherlich irgendwelche, irgendwie gearteten Sommerpausen. Aber wir werden auf jeden Fall noch dafür sorgen, dass wir die vierhundert noch vollkriegen.
Ja, die vierhundert machen wir noch vor den Sommerpausen,
und ähm dann ist übrigens auch ja gewissermaßen einigermaßen Sommerpause, ne, zumindest die politische Arbeit ist ja dann zum Erliegen gekommen
äh Ende der Legislaturperiode, dann beginnt das sogenannte Sommerloch und der Wahlkampf.
Das heißt, ich vermute, dass wir so ab Juli eine äh geringeres äh,
Output haben werden, aber mal schauen, was uns da noch so in das Sommerloch gekippt wird an Jauche.
Ja, irgendwas ist ja immer und das ein oder andere Spezial muss man dann eh nochmal nachziehen, was man schon seit Ewigkeiten äh drauf hat, aber äh da könnt ihr uns mal nicht ganz so am Schlafitchen züppeln äh was so den Wochentakt betrifft. Wir haben jetzt eh auch gerade
noch ein bisschen vorgelegt, aber wie.
Auch immer wir äh freuen uns aber auf jeden Fall, wenn ihr auch das nächste Mal wieder zuhört, wenn's heißt, hallo hier, wir sind's. Wir beiden.
So fängt unser Podcast ja immer an. Hallo, wir sind's.
Die beiden Heinis aus der Netzpolitik. Leute, macht's gut, bis bald.
Bis dahin, ciao, ciao.